this is Jocko podcast number 188 with
David Burke and me Jacque are willing
good evening Dave good evening and on
the last podcast number 187 Dave and I
dug into the first two chapters we tried
to make it a three we only made it to
two of the Marine Corps doctrinal
publication MC dp1 dak three tactics so
if you haven't listened to that podcast
that's 187 then go there and start
because now we're going back to the book
starting with chapter three here we go
chapter three is called gaining
advantage and like the other chapters it
starts with a couple quotes the first
quote in war the power to use two fists
is an incredible asset to feint with one
fist and strike with the other yields an
advantage but a still greater advantage
lies in being able to interchange them
to convert the feint into the real blow
if the opponent uncovers himself and
that's BH Liddell Hart was kind of a
controversial figure a little bit but he
was British officer wounded in World War
one wounded in World War one you know
last podcast we were talking about how
you made it through World War one and
then you and then you involved in World
War two right crazy
BH Liddell Hart is one of those guys who
was wounded in World War one took a
couple years to recover and then went
back into World War One battled a song
wounded again gassed wounded gas taken
off the line and his entire battalion
was wiped out so he ended up being a
writer a military theorist and I'm sure
I'll cover some of his books on here at
some point they're really interesting
books and he had a very interesting
perspective very
I would say contrary in perspective on
warfare especially contrarian in regards
to world war 1 hey this doesn't seem
like it was a great idea when your
battalion gets wiped out the Battle of
the Somme I think that's might be a
thing to walk away with it with and the
other quote that this starts with is the
challenge is to identify and adopt a
concept of warfighting consistent with
our understanding of the nature and
theory of war and the realities of the
modern battlefield what exactly does
this require it requires a concept of
war fighting that will function
effectively in an uncertain chaotic and
fluid environment in fact one that will
exploit these conditions to advantage so
you hear they've mentioned that the
uncertain chaotic that keep saying that
over and over again I think they're
trying to tell us something but isn't it
interesting to look at those uncertain
chaotic things and say to yourself good
where we will exploit these things that
are happening yeah that's our
opportunity yes the chaos is what is our
opportunity to overwhelm our opponent
that's what we want to take advantage of
and there are those of us that when we
see that I'm actually super excited I'm
saying those of us and I'm actually
talking about myself when I see chaos I
actually get excited and love it for
some reason so here we go getting
started gaining an advantage a basic
principle of martial arts is to use the
opponent's strength and momentum against
him to gain more leverage than one's own
muscles alone can generate thereby
gaining an advantage the same concept
applies to tactics we strive to gain
advantage over an adversary by
exploiting every aspect of a situation
to help us achieve victory not by
overpowering him with our own strength
this chapter will discuss several
different ways of generating leverage to
gain advantage over the enemy this is
one of those things that when I saw it
when I read this and when I read this
for the first time I wasn't training
jiu-jitsu when I read it for the second
time I was this had a whole nother
meaning
a whole nother meaning when I read this
and actually understood it I was talking
with one of the guys I trained with I'm
trying to think of who it was I might
have made Greg trained when you when you
learn to move so if if I show you a move
Dave and you've been training jiu-jitsu
for a year and a half you're gonna pick
up 12% of it 20% of it may be the first
time I show it to Dean one time and he
captures 90% of it because he has that
like you try to explain some maneuver
yeah we could do this drill like you
could explain to me the way that you
would do a maneuver in a in a jet plane
and I would understand 10% of it maybe
4% of it I don't know whereas you
explained it to one of your old
teammates from Top Gun and they're gonna
they're gonna understand 90% of their oh
yeah okay I understand all that other
stuff and now you're just tell me this
little tiny detail that I didn't know
cool got it that's what it was like
reading that's what it's like reading
this book for me when I read it later
when I did jujitsu everything when you
when you when you know the way Branca
you see it in all things we just had
that conversation the other day I did I
went back to look at this in my mind I'm
like I'm gonna roofie I want to review
this because I want to kind of have it
fresh in my mind cuz I I've read it I've
read it actually read it a few times I
can't remember exactly the last time I
read it but it was well before any of
any of this and when I read it it wasn't
a review it was it was it was like a
whole new book the way I was reading it
because I was just seeing things in
there that I couldn't make any
connections to before that could make
the connections now parse it because
it's so simple and straightforward but
because the things are saying they apply
everywhere and you can see what this is
saying everywhere and it's true
throughout from the beginning to end you
you see these things in there it's it's
awesome to see it that way
back to the book consider the American
Indian ambush technique a small number
of warriors could would draw superior
force of pursuing cavalry and tack into
a canyon or similar similar closed
terrain there a larger force of warriors
lying in wait would quickly surround and
ambush the soldiers who thought they had
been pursuing a retreating enemy by
exploiting the Cavalry's initial
advantages of strength of momentum the
American Indians were able to seize the
initiative and gain advantage through
the use of this classic ambush method
fire sac are you familiar with that
doctrinal term yes that's basically what
they're describing hey we're gonna
surround you completely and shoot you
yep I used to set that up where I would
capture the thief the friendly seals
that were going through my training
capture them in a fire sack it would be
a bloodbath combined-arms the use of
combined arms is a key means of gaining
advantage it is based on the idea of
presenting the enemy not merely with a
problem but with a dilemma and they've
got that italicized yes it's it's it is
based on the idea of presenting the
enemy not merely with a problem but with
a dilemma a no-win situation
we combine supporting arms organic fires
and maneuver in such a way that any
action the enemy takes to avoid one
threat makes him more vulnerable to
another this is what we do in jujitsu
we got the triangle arm lock sweep
combination happening no matter which
way they're caught in that dilemma which
way are they gonna get tapped out or
swept or end up in a worse position for
example an entrenched enemy should
discover that if he stays hunkered down
in fighting halls marine artillery and
arrow blast amount if he comes out to
attack marine infantry will cut him down
if he tries to retreat marine armor and
air power will pursue him to his
destruction that is combined arms the
combined arms dilemma a good example of
the use of combined arms at the squad
level would be the squad leader
positioning squad automatic weapons and
grenade launchers to provide
port by firewall infantry men with
rifles assault to position the firepower
from the automatic weapons keeps the
enemy in their fighting holes while
grenades make those holes untenable
these supporting fires keep the enemy
from reacting effectively to our
maneuvering infantry force the enemy
forces are placed in a no-win situation
you know what I think of when I think of
one of the best examples that I can
think of when I think of combined arms
effectiveness being used effectively was
when we were in Ramadi and the enemy
would utilize combined arms attacks so
for example u.s. and Iraqi forces u.s.
and Iraqi friendly forces had outposts
we had checkpoints and what the enemy
would do is they would start off from a
very covered position this is a allo
allo threat for them way to attack as
you get into a you get a couple
buildings away you can either start with
mortars or you start with machine-gun
fire so there's a let's say there's an
Iraqi checkpoint and there's a couple
Americans there but it's mostly Iraqi
checkpoint first thing the enemy does is
start lobbing mortars in what does
everyone do and mortars start they all
take it everyone takes cover because you
have to take cover if there's mortars
going off you have to take cover
once you take cover now the enemy gets
up with their machine guns and gets good
position when you start to reveal
yourself they're there with machine guns
now that they've got the machine guns
rocking and rolling they've got your
head down even deeper outcome the RPGs
and the RPGs are coming in and slamming
direct fire into your position and while
that all is happening in comes a
vehicle-borne IEDs that rolls all the
way through the gates and detonates and
blows up so that is what that is a
classic use of combined arms dilemma you
doesn't matter what - way you go you're
gonna be in trouble
yeah for sure and having lived through
that scenario repeatedly and how often
they would do that I think that
distinction of a problem versus a
dilemma is is the critical thing because
with a dilemma you actually have to
react one of your choices can't just be
hey we're gonna ride this thing out and
let it play itself out and you actually
have to react us if you
do nothing that initial move that
they're making that by itself if you
don't react in direct fire you just
stand there that could be the problem
that that ends up being effective for
them so you actually have to respond in
a way then allows them to move down the
road and when the Marine Corps talks
about doing this they don't know if it's
gonna be the aircraft or the indirect
fire or the machine because they don't
know which one it's going to be but the
key is creating a situation that the
enemy has to do something and if they
choose to do nothing good yeah
then the first move is gonna kill them
yeah that isn't typically what happens
but it forces them to do something well
which is what you're looking that's the
advantage you're looking exploit and
being on the receiving of that it sucks
it's awful feeling of what that feels
like if hey we have to do something and
then you start to play it out and in
your mind like if I do this then this
happened and it could be actually
paralyzing if you're not careful that it
will paralyze you and doing nothing
which is every bit as bad yeah there's a
couple things number one obviously we
see this in jujitsu and you get stuck
where the person's coming out with you
with multiple attacks now to your point
if I do a if I attempt to sweep you but
I don't actually attempt to sweep you I
just faint at sweeping you you don't
have to really defend it because I
didn't really do it so therefore if I
try and sweep you if I want to get a
reaction from you I actually have to try
and do it and like you just said if you
don't defend it you're getting swept
yeah so you have to actually do it it
can't just be not that you can't feint
not that we don't you know the Doolittle
faints and and false moves to set people
up because you do that all the time you
do it in combat but if you really want
to get reaction familiy you've got to
commit to that movement it's got to be
real and it's the same thing when you're
dealing with human beings yeah you know
when I say if if I deliver an ultimatum
to you because the project wasn't done
and I go Dave if you don't finish this
project on time you're fired if I say
that I have to actually do it right
otherwise I the friends I lose all this
respect I can't just make these idle
threats they need to be real and on the
receiving end I mean that that for me
and I
but talk about I think the last podcast
about that wreck and a ham I'm so junior
I'm so novice at this and I remember
talking to you about it early on I would
climb like man why am I so tired why do
I get so and one of the things I was
doing is sort of overreacting to every
single thing and exerting myself a
hundred percent all the time and I
remember one of the the thinking about
okay I'm not gonna overreact to these
things that were happening and remember
one of the first times on the
consciously thinking about that on the
mat and somebody was setting up an
armoire time I was aware like he's
sending up an armor and I'm thinking
this is gonna be awesome because I'm not
gonna overreact to this armbar I'm gonna
wait and guess what happened I got
submitted in the armored guard yeah it
was like and it's like it's like you
said it's it has to be the feint has to
be real and that was me and a complete
novice move of I'm totally out maneuver
in this guy he's going for that feint
arm Barca see what he really wants me to
do is over commit to that so it can set
up a choke and I ignored the armbar and
he tapped me about five seconds in an
armbar because I did no reaction to it
and it's and that's really that's what
the dilemma is and on the on the
receiving end is recognizing that feint
could be the death blow if you actually
don't respond to it correctly if he's
not doing it just as a feint he's
actually doing it to reveal your
weakness which is the key to that and
the Marine Corps operates expecting they
don't have some massive numeric
advantage when Corps doesn't go to war
thinking they've got five to one
manpower advantage they go to war with
the numerical disadvantage to create
these points of friction so that a
limited resources create a problem that
the enemy has to respond to and if they
don't respond they kill them anyway yeah
and that's that that's the important
thing so the other part that you
mentioned was you're you you're in this
dilemma what what are you gonna do and
you said you've got to do something and
that is true because the best-case
scenario if I'm if I'm attempting to
catch you in the combined-arms dilemma
or in an armlock the best-case scenario
for me is you don't react and then you
just get you just get crushed by
whatever that first initial salvo is the
what what I would the the worst thing
for me is when you attack me I mean to
be straight up I mean I'm not saying
this works every time
right but if I'm getting attacked one of
the bows most
expected things that you can do back to
me is you attack you so oh you start my
shooting shooting machine guns at me oh
guess what you didn't know I had
claymores out in this surrounding area
and as soon as I thought machine gun
fires I'm clacking off claymores and in
one second like the SOG guys they would
have their Claymore set up and if they
get attacked the first thing they're
doing is igniting claymores so that that
immediately there they get fire
superiority from the Claymore going off
so what can we do and more important how
can we set ourselves up preemptively so
that when these things unfold we have an
immediate action drill that puts us from
the defensive to the offensive very very
quickly when we learned immediate action
drills and the SEAL Teams we were
learning from the Vietnam guys when they
got contacted in the jungle the very
first thing they did was to hit the
ground and everyone unloads a magazine
into their the fire period and a story
that's what's gonna happen you could
decide I as it was the same thing oh we
get contact and there was a great story
that tilt told was everyone dumps their
mag and then there's silence because
everyone dumped their mag on both sides
the the the NVA and the the SOG guys
they all dumped their mags and in their
silence and then it's who can get
reloaded the quickest but what they did
in that moment is take away the
advantage of the enemy because the enemy
is attacking them and their immediate
reaction is oh you're gonna shoot at us
you're gonna try and get us in some kind
of a combined armed dilemma ok cool
watch this because they're waiting for
the b40 rockets they're caught that's
what their goal is and they're gonna try
and maneuver but guess what we're gonna
immediately fire back at you we're gonna
fire back at you hard and then we're
gonna we're gonna see who wins that next
little race - who can yank the next gen
yeah and even the idea of being event
issah paiting and being prepared for
that expecting that to happen which
actually in Ramadi we were I wasn't we
weren't shocked that the enemy was
attacking us we actually did some
preparation and some thought went into
that in some of the things and the
combined combined arm side and I know
this as an aviator look the enemy
doesn't have an unlimited number of
directions to attack us from all the
time they're actually places where they
can attack areas are we control areas we
have dominance over and so if you think
about they actually had a limited number
of things
could do and if we prepared enough we
could actually have pre-planned
responses into the most likely areas
that immediately we could respond with
as we're ducking getting our heads down
as opposed to no preparation no
expectation that's happening and
actually then we can't respond well but
the idea of being attacked in combat
it's absolutely an eventualities we
should prepare for and there's things
you can do to respond just like you said
and we would do that I mean that's why
we didn't get overwhelmed when they
attacked us because we had a plan for
how to respond to that yes back to the
book modern tactics is combined arm
tactics that is it combines the effects
of various arms infantry armor artillery
and aviation to achieve the greatest
possible effect against the enemy
artillery and infantry for example are
normally employed together because of
their mutually reinforcing capabilities
the infantry provides close support to
the artillery protecting them from
dismounted threats while the artillery
provides the infantry with timely close
accurate and continuous fire support the
strength of the arms complement the
strengths of the arms complement and
reinforce each other at the same time
the weaknesses and vulnerabilities of
each arm are protected or offset by the
capabilities of the other while a
division commander in 1941 General
Patton had the following comments
regarding combined arms there is a
tendency in each separate unit to be a
one-handed puncher by that I mean that
the rifleman wants to shoot the tanker
to charge the artillery man to fire that
is not the way to win battles if the
band played a piece first with the
piccolo
then with the brass horn then with the
clarinet and then with the trumpet there
would be a hell of a lot of noise but no
music to get harmony music each
instrument must support the others to
get harmony in battle each weapon must
support the other team play wins
cover move yes it's so huge it's so
important to think about that and look
that's one of the beautiful things about
the ethos of the Marine Corps and why
TBS is so important is when we say every
Marine is a rifleman that's not just
words that's that's a real now does that
mean every Marine is as competent as an
infantryman in the Marine Corps no it
doesn't if you're an infantryman you're
gonna be more confident in those things
but at the basic school for a Marine
officer I had exposure to virtually
every single arms profession in the
Marine Corps and in business we see this
when we talk about hey if I'm on the
sales team do I need to be an expert in
marketing no do I need to have a hundred
percent understanding of what's going on
with IT no but actually what you need is
a good understanding of that and a
relationship strong enough to leverage
what they're doing not just because it's
helped but because actually that can be
the difference maker in you being
successful and the ones where we see
them wall themselves off from their silo
and don't have any basic understanding
they can't leverage that capability when
they needed the most and in the Marine
Corps I was not an expert in artillery I
was not an expert but I understood it
enough to be able to communicate with
them and understand what they could
contribute and be more importantly how I
can help them which in turn let them do
the exact same thing for me and in
business too weekly they wall themselves
off this is what I do you do that and
they they're on the opposite side of
offense inside the same company it
doesn't mean you have to be a hundred
percent of everything they do but you
have to understand it and how it
contributes to what you're doing
cover movie you you got a cover and move
do it first law of combat cover move why
is it the first caught law of combat
because that's what teamwork is because
you have to work it if if you're not
working together if you don't have a
team that's working together you don't
know the other men they don't matter I
could give you this great simple plan
yeah and if you and I don't have a good
relationship and when it doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't matter what about
prioritize next year oh but we're not
working together as a team doesn't
matter maneuver maneuver provides us a
means to gain advantage over the enemy
in too many battles one or both sides of
to gain advantage in combat through
firepower and attrition in World War one
one side would rush across no-man's land
under murderous fire an attempt to push
an opponent off desired terrain if the
attack succeeded and few did the evicted
forces counter-attacked in the same
manner usually reoccupying the same
terrain they had before these battles
were firepower and attrition contests
and the advantage lay with the side that
had the most personnel and equipment to
expend to the tune of 60,000 casualties
in one day the cost in casualties and
equipment was high and often produced no
decisive results we want to avoid this
type of engagement we want to avoid this
type of engagement this type of
engagement okay from a combat situation
obviously we understand what that is we
don't want it from an individual dealing
with another individual from a
leadership perspective if what I get out
of my confrontation with you is that
I've expended a bunch of leadership
capital I've damaged our relationship
I've made you feel insecure or like
untrusted but I got my way in the end I
gained like above I gained a little bit
of authority over you got your 10 yards
about my 10 yards of authority it's a
it's a type of engagement that I see
people do and they don't understand how
negative it is all they're do they win
and this is the sad thing like when you
charge that German line and you take
4,000 casualties and you move 50 yards
forward and you raise your hands and you
say I won and you're actually standing
up and saying I won you're standing on
the backs of 4,000 dead men and you
you're holding up your arm saying I won
so when you get in an argument with one
your subordinates or with one of your
bosses or one of your peers and you you
you inflict damage and you expend
ammunition and you expend leadership
capital and
you stand up and you see you come
through with the victory and you stand
up in you raise your arms you say I won
look underneath your feet and see what
you're standing on because you're
standing upon your reputation you're
standing on your dead your dying
reputation you're standing on your your
expended leadership capital you're
standing on top of a of a wounded
relationship so don't do that
back to the book traditionally maneuver
is meant moving in a way that gains
positional advantage for example we may
maneuver by anvil opening by enveloping
and exposed enemy flank or by denying
enemy terrain critical to his goals we
may maneuver by threatening the enemy's
lines of communication and forcing them
to withdraw where you aim a manoeuvre by
seizing a position which allows us to
bring effective fire to bear against the
enemy but which protests protects us
against enemy fires we may maneuver in
other dimensions as well for instance we
may also maneuver in time by increasing
relative speed and operating in a faster
tempo than the enemy normally we
maneuver both in time and space to gain
advantage and ultimately victory at the
least possible cost there are so many
other ways to move forward towards your
strategic goal and people are just
absolutely blind to these ways and the
only way that they feel it's like they
can't recognize anything other than I'm
going to attack you if I if I'm not
attacking you then then how can I win
they don't understand that there's so
many other different ways to win and
again I'm talking about a leadership
leadership up or down the chain of
command peer relationship whatever the
only way I feel like I can beat Dave is
by imposing my will upon him and that's
how I'm gonna win when the reality is
that's actually the worst way to win if
there is a tactic that is disconnected
from the strategy it's it's virtually
guaranteed to lose and that's why
there's a difference between being
tactical
what the tactic is the tactic might be
you come in from the north and I bring
my forces up the middle and I use that
might be the tactic to do that
but if there's not a connection to what
the strategic outcome is it's guaranteed
to not have the impact that you want and
what we see is all too often is there's
no understanding of why we're doing the
thing that we're doing other than for
the reason to do it I was with the
company a couple weeks ago when I was we
were looking at personnel the number of
people had him in I had gotten some
feedback in a survey that a couple folks
at the company weren't real happy they
didn't really feel that they were well
used in that they their contribution was
marginal or they didn't feel like
they're a big part of the team and one
of those feedbacks was to figure out
what that is and I'd asked that it was a
CEO oh and I asked him hey there's a guy
on this department and this is some of
the feedback and his answer was a good
well he was actually a defensive hire we
hired this guy in because I was afraid
of our comput he's competent guy but I
was afraid my competition would get him
first so we brought him in like okay
there's there's a there's a reason to do
that and so what are you doing with him
like not much we really just didn't want
our competition to get him I'm thinking
this person has met the threshold by
which if he goes to your competition he
could be damaging that's how competent
and capable of this person is so you've
made the mind in mindsets like I need to
bring this guy to my team because he's
too good if the other person gets him
and then your answer was to do nothing
with him and just that idea of and he
was so stoked that they had gotten this
guy before their competitor gotten them
and so you know what tactical big they
won they won the exact I got this guy I
got jock onto my team before that my
competition does what are you doing them
now nothing that that was the move that
was the plan and just kind of that
missing I've just you've done nothing
for the big picture naturally this
person was gonna be more motivated over
time when he leaves your company to
bulldoze you because of what you did to
him in doing that and you see that like
man this is and it's not a hard problem
sob you can it when you see it from the
outside but from the inside it was we
won we got the win we pulled this guy
over the reason I took a note while you
were talking and it's a little it's a
disconnected subject but I'm gonna bring
it up anyways just to make sure it
doesn't
slip away one of the things of dealing
with another company we pay people money
right and people talk about well how do
you how do you how do you make someone
happy right and what leaked what levers
can you pull right you can pay them more
you can give them less work you can give
them more rewarding you can give them
ownership of things right like that's so
there's there's like the money and then
there's everything else right everything
else give people ownership of things but
and I wrote down the word fate because
one of the best possible ways you can
compensate a human being is by giving
them more control over their own fate
and so often this is not used as a lever
and it's a powerful leader it's not like
it's not like okay you know what I'm
gonna manipulate Dave into wanting to do
good work by giving by by giving him
this false sense that I'm gonna give him
some control over his own fate but
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about actually giving the person
control over their own fate and all of a
sudden Dave looks up and goes well you
know I don't have to do this today or I
can and if I do I'll be rewarded and
things will go better for me I control
my destiny I control my future just a
good way to again I guess the reason I
follow this is it's a maneuver that you
can use as a leader it's instead of me
barking and crippling my relationship
and wounding my subordinate why not lift
them up improve the relationship and get
them to do what I want them to do by
giving them more control over their own
fate what is really helpful as a leader
to be able to understand to do those
things is not not just the strategically
as to what we talked about in the last
podcast which is actually care about
them actually believe and care about
them is one thing that guides you to
recognize that that would be so critical
for them and the return on that would be
that the loyalty and all the things that
that person that you really want you
really want is for them to do it anyway
and the it's not a trick it's it's
actually believing in that person's
livelihood and happiness
things that make that person's life
better is to believe it that's what how
you allow them to have that thing which
is you know I know you want more control
over your fate we all do and I'm not
doing it as is it as a play I'm doing it
because I care about you that much and
the irony is the return of that is I get
what I want yeah if there's a credibly
loyal person that will do anything for
me it's one of the hardest things to
explain about all this stuff is that it
works when you make a maneuver like that
when I say Dave you know you take more
control over your own fate it works and
the person will do step up and do better
but the and it will be much much much
better for Dave but what you would leave
the complete bonuses is that it would be
much much much better for me and I'm
gonna win because Dave is happy and when
Dave's happy Dave does better work and
when Dave does better work we do better
as a team and when we do betters team I
win meanwhile the Contra converse of
that is me thinking nope
this is me I'm gonna take care of me and
Dave therefore needs to do what I say
and now guess what Dave doesn't do his
good work he doesn't put out as much
effort and Dave and the team doesn't do
as well and now I look bad next section
exploiting the environment the use of
the efficient the the use of the
environment offers tremendous
opportunities to gain advantage over the
enemy we must understand the
characteristics of any environment where
we may have to operate jungle desert
mountain arctic riverine urban more
importantly we must understand how the
effects of terrain weather and periods
of darkness or reduced visibility impact
our own and our adversaries ability to
fight so this is another one of those
statements like we heard on the last
podcast where you wouldn't think that
somebody needs to tell you you must
understand the characteristics of the
environment where you're going to
operate seems like that's super real
obvious yeah and yet there it is in
plain English broken down for all of us
idiots because so often we overlook the
fact that we're in a different
environment or a new environment or
environments it's shifting or an
environment that we never even took a
good look at in the
first place next terrain our objective
is to employ tactics that make terrain
an advantage to us and a disadvantage to
our opponent if terrain impacts on our
maneuver and influences our tactical
dispositions we must understand terrain
and comprehend its effects as it may
limit our movement reduce our visibility
or restrict our fires we must understand
understand what effects it has on the
enemy and on his abilities to detect or
engage us we must be aware that the
enemy also seeks advantage from terrain
we must understand that terrain shapes
the enemy's maneuver and dispositions as
well as our own this is for you you know
how I'm always saying hey for the
business world this is not for the
business world of them but to say when
you're a young leader and you're gonna
be on the ground fighting army special
operations marine corps whatever unit
you're with the terrain is like the
thing that brings you from sort of its
it brings you to the next level
understanding terrain brings you to the
next level if you don't understand
terrain and how to use it how the
enemy's gonna use it you are a baby this
is like this brings you into your
teenage years but without and I believe
me I met I've met commanders or leaders
at every level that do poor babies when
it came to terrain they didn't
understand these incredible you know I'm
saying it's like teenage but at the same
time it's also like masters if you are
good at terrain if you're good at
understanding terrain it's night and day
yeah and it's it actually helps solve so
many other problems if you're deficient
in resources and all the in combat or
anywhere if you don't have all the
things that you think you need enough
guns enough people whatever if you
occupy the most critical terrain
it actually is a huge hedge against not
having all the things you wish you had
more guns and bombs and okay we don't
have those but you can have all the
resources in the world and if you're not
in the right place to utilize them it
isn't gonna work that's true in combat
that's true that's true anywhere and it
isn't just oh the high ground that the
biggest hill is a bit not always it's
actually being able to just see what the
terrain looks like and recognizing that
is the best place to be to recognize
where the commenting event is going to
occur to bring my forces to bear its
here and I see that and I've got to get
control that that terrain and now when
it comes now when we do translate it
back to the business side there's a
couple big key points here okay and it's
like what they say about the
counterinsurgency right the decisive
terrain in a counterinsurgency is not of
airfield and it's not a mountain and
it's not a beachhead it's the people
well guess what the torah' decisive
terrain is in an organization and in a
business it's the people all day long
that's the decisive terrain so what you
have to do is you have to get those
people on board with the program so when
a counterinsurgency what you have to do
is you have to get the local populace to
support what you're doing what do you
have to do in a business you have to get
the local populace that people that work
for you on board with what you're doing
that's the decisive terrain so you've
got to know what that terrain consists
of and it is equally important as the
terrain the high ground that you might
see on the battlefield the other part of
this is the moral terrain where are you
at morally and I had this conversation
with a CEO that was complaining to me
that there was bad that actually this
was two CEOs in a row they were both
complaining about competitors that were
very good at lying about them and their
products so there's there's you know
this other company which is slightly
bigger than ours and every time we do
something there they're putting out bad
propaganda they're lying about us and it
get but it gets traction and then I saw
the same another company same thing and
and you know it gets brutal it gets
brutal and you know you can watch the
news and you can watch politicians on on
the news and you you listen to what the
two sides of of the two different
parties are saying and they're
completely
Lee like there's no possible way that
that they that there's that they're even
close to any middle ground right there
saying completely opposite things and so
that's what these companies deal with
companies do the same things they will
straight-up lie about what another
company is doing and what's the defense
against that well the defense is that
you have the truth and if you have the
truth and you don't weaponize it you
need to weaponize it as where I ended up
telling both you CEOs you need to
weaponize the truth you need to get the
truth out there you need to go on the
offense with the truth you have the high
ground but you're sitting there wait let
in someone drop drop lie bombs on you
that you're gonna sit there and you're
gonna be in the combined-arms dilemma
cuz you're gonna come out looking
looking bad because you're now
backpedaling trying to explain things
that shouldn't need to be explained in
the first place and if you actually
occupy that moral if you actually do
occupy the high ground there and and you
actually do have the truth you can be
transparent and honest about it you
don't have anything to hide because
those things I mean those aren't those
are lies and if you actually have that
then you actually have the weapon and
you occupy that high ground because
you're doing it the right way
you're not lying you're not you're not
doing those things and and if you're
actually covering some of those things
up if you actually are hiding some of
that and you've advocated that moral
piece of this then you're gonna lose
again this different you're gonna lose
so you not only have to have oh wait a
second you might not lose you might not
lose immediately right you might win the
big you might win the tactical battle
yeah you might win that with some lies
and some cover-up for sure you can win
that way that long-term long game that
strategy you're you're lose
strategically for sure gives a little
example here lieutenant Harrell Kaiser
of 1st battalion 7th Marines knew how to
use terrain to gain an advantage in
November 1950 his company was ordered to
seize a key piece of terrain at talk
talk Tong pass during the march out of
the Chosun reservoir area
lieutenant Kaiser had only 20 Marines
left in his platoon and the pass was
heavily defended by the Chinese using a
flanking ridgeland Ridgeline to conceal
his approach lieutenant Kaiser
skillfully and
the enemy from the rear and quickly
routed the Chinese out of their well
entrenched position today as in Korea
the intelligent use of terrain has
become a standard practice for Marines
weather adverse weather he called rain
in pedes combat operations actually a
I'll say this we you know we used to say
when it was raining
we'd say good operating weather because
it is because guess what when it's cold
and it's raining guess what your
sentries are doing the centuries that
you're trying to sneak by they're inside
their little guard hut they got their
hood pulled over their head so impedes
combat operation sometimes you can use
to do it you can often use it to your
advantage the military unit that is best
prepared to operate in these conditions
will gain advantage over its opponent
during the breakout from Chosun
reservoir November 1950 Marines
demonstrated time and time again the
ability to use harsh weather to their
advantage over a deterrent determined
enemy the assault of able company 1st
battalion 1st Marine Regiment on hill
1:08 won in a blinding snowstorm is such
an example
despite visibility of only 25 yards the
company was able to coordinate a
combined arms attack and envelop this
key piece of terrain that blocked the
break out of the 1st Marine Regiment
using a snowstorm to mask its movement
able company surprised and annihilated
the Chinese defenders thereby opening a
route for the rest of the division if we
already used weather to our advantage we
must train and prepare rigorously to
operate in all climatic conditions we
must be able to operate our equipment
and employ our weapons effectively in
hot cold and wet environments literally
in every clime and place you know I like
about weather when it comes to comparing
these leadership principles is that it's
just unpredictable unpredictable and you
can't control it and it's this random
thing that you know which which which
hits every you know every company every
business every leadership situation
there's things that you do too
so what do you do you figure out how to
mitigate you've planned you you have
contingencies for these situations and
as you can see here you trained to be
prepared for this idea of control you
talked about I've heard you talk about
weather in the past I use it as an
example a lot because in aviation
weather makes a massive impact in what
you do in an airplane the reality is is
that when it comes to something like
weather his idea of a snowstorm
we're in 100% of control of how we react
to it we're a hundred percent of control
of what we choose to do based on this
blinding snowstorm and the reality is
you know what most people do in a
blinding snowstorm
they but no because that's what that's
what most people do and so and I think
it was really the point you were making
at the very beginning is you know what
the the best year they I am praying for
a snow storm I want I want the worst
possible environment cuz I know more
than likely that other guy that other
company they're gonna wither in that and
we're gonna go on the attack and and the
idea of most Marines it's an I'm a human
being I know what it feels like to be
cold I don't like being cold it sucks
but to take that to use at it to your
advantage and actually welcome this
inclement weather this giant blinding
snowstorm that's what good leaders do is
they get people around them to do those
things you know the guy who puts on an
orange guy who puts on an orange vest in
a snowstorm hurt yeah that's right
that's that's an amazing situation to
think about given the environment where
most people like I'm just gonna hole up
and I can't deal with this it's too cold
it's too biting it's too hard and that's
the vehicle used to actually what I want
the weather to be bad to be able to
recognize you are a hundred percent
control of how you react to that is is
this is a huge differentiator that most
people just completely overlooked I
can't deal with the weather it's not
like I can't do anything about this
actually you can oh yes you can
periods of darkness or reduced
visibility units that can operate
effectively during hours of darkness or
periods of reduced visibility often gain
significant advantage over their
opponent reduced visibility can make the
simplest of tasks difficult to
accomplish this obvious disadvantage can
be turned on its head and used to our
advantage by a commander whose forces
are trained equipped able and willing to
operate at night night operations can
produce great gains against a force that
cannot or will not operate at night
operating during periods of reduced
visibility creates tempo by adding
another 10 to 12 hours to the day for
fighting the psychological impact of
night fighting is also great and can
produce significant rewards so what does
that translate to that translate to look
at what is hard for your competitor and
what's hard for you and your competitor
and then get good at it just get good at
it suck it up and get good at it yeah a
good example of tactical impact of night
attacks was found in the battle for
Okinawa during World War 2 Marine Forces
were essentially stalemated by the
presence of a strong Japanese defensive
line in the coral ridges of southern
Okinawa after days of ineffective
attacks by the 7th Marine Regiment the
regimental commander elected to attack
under cover of darkness at 0 3:30 on 12
June 1945 the 1st and 2nd battalions of
the 7th Marines advanced using a road
that intersected the ridge as a guide
Colonel Edward W Snedeker commanding
officer of the 7th Marines at the time
noted two companies one from each of the
1st and 2nd battalions got across the
valley during the night into position on
the ridge during the early morning when
the Japanese came out to cook breakfast
they found themselves a little bit of a
surprise the Japanese defenders were not
used to US forces attacking at night the
use of Darkness allowed the Marines to
occupy positions along the crest of
Konishi Ridge literally without firing a
shot from these positions the Marines
dislodged the enemy from their
entrenched positions and moved onward
until the Japanese defenders were
annihilated so you train to get good at
something that the competitors not good
at and then you execute on it or you
just sack up and execute on something
that you you know they're not gonna
expect this one so let's bring it yeah
and the the feeling of the the
discomfort and the pain and all the
negative things that you might associate
with operating in those type of
environments which is the reason people
aren't doing it the feeling of winning
the satisfaction that comes from all
that work and all that pain going into
that when you are annihilating the enemy
and they're not even aware of it vastly
outweighs whatever discomfort you might
be feeling when they hey we're gonna
suck it up and operate in bad weather or
we're gonna do things our competition
doesn't want to do because it sort of
sucks it does suck it's extra time it's
actually whatever it is winning makes
all that go away all those all that it's
all it just goes away and you're that
feeling of being victorious in that
environment makes all that worth it and
just the willingness to just do like you
said we're just gonna do the work that
they are not willing to do and that's
gonna be the difference complementary
forces complementary forces the idea of
fix and flank are an important way of
gaining an advantage the idea behind
complementary forces is to use our
forces as a nutcracker
we seek to crush the enemy between two
or more actions consider the case of an
enemy riflemen firing from behind a tree
if one marine fires from the front the
enemy rifleman is protected by the tree
if the Marine maneuvers and attempts to
fire from behind the enemy riflemen
merely moves to the other side of the
tree to maintain his protection however
two Marines can place our opponent in a
dilemma one can fire from the front
while the other sneaks around and fires
from the enemy flow fires at the enemy
from the flank career the opponent is
now vulnerable to one or the other of
the two Marines he cannot use the tree
for protection against both flank flank
flank flank cover and move
cover and flick the idea the same idea
applies to air-to-air tactics did you
just get like a little chill up your
spine the same idea applies to
air-to-air tactics upon detecting enemy
aircraft a flight of fighter a flight of
fighters splits into two or more
elements beyond air-to-air missile range
they approach the enemy aircraft from
multiple directions and varying
altitudes no matter how the enemy
aircraft moves dives climbs turns or
twists it is exposed how often I always
whenever I think of you and Top Gun I
always think of you one-on-one against
one other person that's not the way the
game is played occasionally as it played
that way it is it's a small part of it
it's definitely a part of it and those
skills are important but the
preponderance of the time is multiple
forces large forces against large forces
okay large being how many aircraft on
one side the smallest would be four the
biggest would be maybe 25 geez would you
guys do drills with 25 the culminating
events up at Fallon you know the final
exercises at both top gun in the air
wing training which is carrier training
for war would be 2025 airplanes would
you guys be sitting up there you see you
guys every time that area carrier
airwing came through to do a deployment
they'd come through and flag against you
guys every time they come up through
Fallon for three weeks and how what
cycle where they are we've getting one a
quarter one Air Wing a quarter yeah
that's about right yeah every three to
four months sometimes a little more a
little less but about every three months
an Air Wing every two to three months an
airline would come through the entire
airway did you guys psychologically let
them start to do better at the end or
what you just destroy them the whole
time they would get better they
absolutely would and not not the game of
them they would get better now we would
also we would try to represent
traditional enemy tactics and so they
were working through problem sets but it
got to the point that uh narrowing
against Air Wing they would get to a
point that that they executed the
tactics correctly they would be
successful on the arrow ensign for sure
where you say Air Wing against Air Wing
yeah so they go against themselves no
they they would go against the trainers
that
be representing an enemy airs out to you
guys that's the top gun instructors it's
the top gun and the we I'm complaint
it's actually called Air Wing training
that's the name up at file and so
there's Top Gun and Air Wing training
two separate entities we would fly
together to two in the same airplanes at
the same sort of the same squadron
against the actual American arrowing
that would come in from whatever carrier
coming through and they bring their jets
from their squadrons standing ready to
deploy against enemy that was called Air
Wing training so we would represent an
enemy Air Wing got it and so this is
this is like the exact same thing that I
ran right it's hey I've got some seals
and we have some other role players that
aren't quite in trade at but they're
just whatever they're gonna come and
help out and it's it's art and we
simulate enemy tactics and the and
exactly as you just said if the seals
that were going through the training if
they did what they were supposed to do
and executed the tactics they would win
they'd be successful they would they
would take casters it'd be hard but they
would win and a matter of fact if they
were really good they would dominate
yeah I gave you guys a decentralized
command and prioritize and execute and
simple plans and people covering a
movement they would actually did they
would actually dominate for sure and we
wouldn't just roll over to let them win
cuz we wanted them to go home with the
victory that's not how it worked and
actually what would happen by the end of
their training they understood the
fundamental principles they needed to
you know and if Airmen came through and
at the end they weren't doing those
things not only would they not win they
sometimes wouldn't be qualified to go
out there to deploy and that was that's
now that's a rare event but there are
times you said I'm like you did not
actually completely did you guys reload
them yeah they would they would so we
would do that to reload them you gotta
salute lack of training again sorry yeah
they're actually getting ready to go to
war yeah this isn't just a how do you
feel and this is you actually have to
demonstrate the things but if they did
which usually they did these are smart
guys they started applying the tactics
and understand what they're doing
correctly and implement the principles
we thought they would be successful it
would work and it worked most of the
time and and you know you know which
units which air wings came through that
didn't do that
those that had the commanders that said
I've got this figured out I don't need
those are the ones that would that would
struggle the most what a shocker
what a surprise so most of the
air-to-air combat that you trained in
was you were at least with the wingman
right yeah and it's interesting you said
that because we would do these big
culminating exercises with this whole
bunch of airplanes but actually being
able to maneuver 20 airplanes that
actually led to flexibility where I
could break off you and I could just
break away from the entire Air Wing if
it required and you and I would being
Sola was a bad idea it's almost never a
good idea to be by yourself but if you
had just one other airplane just like
that story with the guy with the tree if
you had just one other machine out there
with you you could maneuver in
relationship to each other to put the
enemy in a position that if they are
active one they get killed by the other
and vice versa so this is I'm actually a
little bit disappointed that this is the
first time for this for you because this
is like full-on the cover and move as I
like as I say
when I talk about cover move and I say
well once the enemy's killed my partner
what are they gonna do to me like it's
bad for me like if it's you and me at
once they kill you like it that's really
sucks for you because guess what it's
gonna be just bad for me because they're
coming for me yes and so that's covered
move in the air is 100% how you have to
roll 100% if you were out there you know
we called it a raging single there's
Dave when we'd have these giant screens
and you could watch and all these
computer screens a little icon and
there's Dave by himself down and you'd
see it and what you could watch from the
TV screen is all the enemy forces
maneuvering on Dave and there's Dave
down there running by himself
and you just set your watch because
Dave's but if you had one other guy and
it's not always just one sometimes
there's more than one but if you had
just one other guy you actually could
maneuver with that other person and
create real problems for the enemy and
as soon as you were alone as soon as you
were a raging single people are setting
their stopwatch just because you're just
you're just gonna die you're not gonna
survive are you voluntarily is that a
guy that goes oh you know what I can
take this guy over here
is that what created the raging single
know typically what it is is a guy who's
lost awareness it's pretty uncommon
especially at that stage in your career
to think to voluntarily say I got this
I've got this it's actually not really
realizing what's happening and what that
person would do he'd have his face
buried in the radar screen he'd get
locked into this one guy he thinks he's
fighting against thinking it's one
against one and he loses sight of the
big picture he goes down the wrong path
and he doesn't recognize that he's
actually getting maneuvered on and that
one guy that he's looking to target is
actually baiting him into moving into
this place it wasn't always another
airplane sometimes it was a sand bush we
called it where pull himself over train
with her surface air missiles there's a
whole bunch of things going on there but
it was typically someone who lost
situational awareness
did you hear Jim Conkel talking about
being his p38 and he calls break break
which means hey we got to break off and
go attack and there was loss of calms or
whatever so he just breaks by himself
yeah and sure enough I mean he took out
some bad guys but then he got taken out
yes he was you know got maneuvered on
yep for sure whole new whole new like
category I can talk about now back to
the book sunsoo described this concept
as Cheng and Chi Cheng is the more
direct obvious action it fixes the enemy
the Chi is the unexpected or
extraordinary action it is the bid for a
decision or as we call it today the main
effort these two actions work together
against the enemy the two actions are
inseparable and can be interchangeable
in battle the Chiang may become the Chi
the concept is basic but it can but it
can be implemented in a variety of
combinations limited only by our
imagination creativity yeah totally you
know it's like limited only by our
doctrine lit only by our standard
operating procedures limited only by
what you were taught in school
No limited by your actual imagination
surprise achieving surprise can greatly
increase leverage in fact surprise can
often prove decisive we try to achieve
surprise through deception stealth and
ambiguity
that one never really thought too much
about that the fact that ambiguity can
create surprise you're not really sure
what I'm gonna do kind of ambiguous war
is based on deception stated sunsoo we
use deception to mislead our opponents
with regard to our real intentions
capabilities by employing deception we
try to cause our opponents to act in
ways that will eventually prove
prejudicial for them we may use you know
it's you know it's awesome about these
books and this is very interesting this
is like the ultimate the ultimate in
lack of ego so you know who wrote this
book the United States Marine Corps some
a marine yeah but you know what there
was probably four seven I don't know
there was something like that there was
a guy and there was one of those guys
that was really on it and there was one
of those guys that he was the old dog
and he was like hey listen let me you
know you can write the chapter but let
me tell you what you need to hit there
was a guy that reserved that for sure
and you know we'll never know who he is
because the Marine Corps he was a Marine
we know that and that's all we need to
know him so he wrote that line right
there
this eminently qualified marine rose
that's right eventually that by
employing deception we try to cause her
opponents to act in ways that will
eventually prove prejudicial for them we
may use deception to mislead the enemy
as to the time and location of our
pending attack we may use deception to
create the impression that our forces
are larger than they really are we may
we hope the enemy will realize this
deception only when it is too late for
them to react Marines have often relied
on deception to mislead an enemy in
regard to the location of amphibious
landings marine used this deception to
create the illusion of force where there
was none an Operation Desert Storm
lieutenant general boomer stated that
stated the situation which incessant
ated an extensive descent deception
operation we're taking on eleven Iraqi
divisions with two marine divisions are
forced to ratio our force two ratios are
our force ratios are horrible we don't
want him to know that the Marines
created tasks for
Troi 460 Marines imitated the activities
of a 16,000 man division using
loudspeakers dummy tanks and artillery
and helicopters conducting simulated
resupply surprise can be generated
through stealth stealth is used to the
advantage when maneuvering against the
enemy it provides less chance of
detection by the enemy leaving him
vulnerable to surprise action for which
he may be unprepared Marines may also
employ stealth by lying in wait for an
approaching enemy in ambush the ambush
is perhaps the most effective means of
surprising opponents especially at the
lower tactical level we're surprised
through stealth is easiest to achieve we
also we can also achieve surprise
through ambiguity it is usually
difficult to conceal all our movements
from the enemy but we can sometimes
confuse him as to the meaning of what he
sees sunsoo said the enemy must not know
where I intend to give battle for if he
does not know where I intend to give
battle he must prepare in a great many
places when he prepares in a great many
places those I have to fight in any one
place will be few ambiguity was central
to the tactics of world war ii german
blitzkrieg an attacking blitzkrieg
involved multiple thrusts with
reinforcements following which ever
thrusts were most successful the
multitude of thrusts created paralyzing
uncertainty because the opponent could
not determine which constituted the real
attack there was nothing secret about
the German attack but it was ambiguous
on a massive scale that's like if it
starts off with the opposite of the
concentration of effort which is sort of
one of the fundamental principles of war
concentration of effort yeah yeah we're
gonna mass our efforts we're gonna
concentrate our efforts gonna focus our
efforts well what we're doing foot
scrapers we're actually gonna spread
that out initially and then once we see
a gap yeah to see what the gap is and
then you're yeah absolutely then we're
coming in hot and this idea you were
talking about stealth you're talking
about envy you
I got to live this in an airplane where
I went from a regular airplane like an
f-18 and an f-16 I flew those four years
and then I got to fly a stealth airplane
I've started flying the f-22 and has all
these attributes that that the other
airplanes didn't have but you know what
we never did in the f-22 no matter how
powerful and invisible all those things
we still didn't do the frontal assault
we still created maneuvers that created
even more ambiguity and leverage this
thing people think like you if you get
the advantage that means you go straight
at them and run them over it's like that
that's it - not what it means it it just
allows you to create even more confusion
more ambiguity and what that means is
the place and the opportunity to
recognize where the weakness is there's
more of that it gives you more
opportunity to see where there's gaps up
here but then you still look for those
gaps and you take even more advantage of
what you're doing and that's how it an
incredibly small number of stealth
airplanes can wipe out a much bigger so
the force ratios or even less in an
airplane in a stealth airplane so I only
need four Raptors who I might need 16
Hornets because I can create even more
ambiguity and the opportunity for those
maybe used to be one or two gaps and now
there's gonna be four or five or six and
I create based on that exact same
principle and once that happens we all
go into that hole and we fill that and
we exploit them and wipe them out with a
force ratio on a missile ratio that's
even less than it was in an older
machine and when you see the reaction of
an enemy who simply doesn't understand
what's happening man that's a good
feeling
because in a Hornet in a legacy machine
it was still you against me I always saw
you you always saw me if I outmaneuvered
you I would still win but rarely were
you surprised by it you might have had a
hard time reacting to it there was
things I had that you couldn't do but
you saw it coming you you were aware
that when you are having to react to
something you don't understand and you
don't Knight attacks ambushes then you
just simply don't know what's happening
the the force multiplier of that is
significantly higher then when they see
you and you're just you're just out
outmaneuver them which is actually
fairly rare in combat when they see
what's going on it's usually kind of a
stalemate
Delta platoon task unit bruiser Seth
stone JP the crew well they was like one
of the early times that they did like a
deception and then an overwatch and then
a flanking overwatch it was literally
called like the flank overwatch
so they had a main overwatch and they
had like a little flanker position but I
remember Seth called me up and he was so
happy because you what happened was as
they started killing bad guys the other
bad guys didn't know what was happening
they didn't understand and they
literally like put down their weapons
and like just walked away and then they
just left because normally as you know
when the guys would set up an overwatch
position and started killing people then
the bad guys would bring it and
eventually get up not really a
clandestine overwatch position but a
reinforced fighting position is what
most of the overwatch is in the Battle
of Ramadi turned into but but this on
this one I remember the first time that
they did this and it was you know Seth
was all excited he was like they they
gave up they didn't know what was happy
they didn't know where they were getting
shot out from it was just they just left
the dead and let him bleed out and just
got away cuz they were totally
overwhelmed yeah as you just described
the they did not know what was happening
and same thing with with Charlie did it
too the first time well it wasn't the
first time but when they started using
boats where we are all of a sudden in
areas you know Charlie Patton's showing
up in areas where the enemy had no
freaking idea that Americans would be in
these spots and be able to engage them
yeah when they ruled out this location
as a possible enemy advance meaning for
us when that was ruled out and then it
happened what the psychological impact
of that is this cannot be happening I
simply do not understand what's
happening well what can be happening
yeah why are my friends are getting
killed right now yes how is this
possible right it's possible
native minds of tu bruzer that's right
coming at you from that those boats man
that was remember that I remember that
yeah that first one we did was awesome
[Applause]
trapping the enemy modern tactics is
based not on pushing the enemy but on
trapping him another excellent way of
gaining advantage trapping is the
desired result of the application of
combined arms fire maneuver or
complementary force tactics why do we
want to trap the enemy instead of just
push him a pushing contest is seldom
decisive the side that is pushed out
comes back the next day still full in
the fight we have to fight him again and
again and fortune unfortunately in
Vietnam many of our battles were pushing
battles we were always able to push the
enemy off the ground he held and to
inflict casualties on him he just
withdrew regrouped placed his losses
replaced his losses and came back to
fight us again the result was a series
of indecisive actions and a seemingly
endless war however if we can trap our
enemy we have a better opportunity to
win decisively you know this is you know
from a leadership perspective what we're
doing here is we're winning the tactical
battle like I'm a Dave do it like you're
damn right Dave you better do it I told
you to do and you're like fine tactical
win you you and you go back but you
heaven you you don't still understand
why you're doing what you're doing and
then I don't do it very well and you
don't do it very well many of history's
decisive battles have been trapping
actions recall how Roman legions were
trapped at kunai or the German divisions
at Stalingrad trapping gains advantage
by disrupting the enemy's mental process
while he attempts to think through the
dilemma we have placed him in trapping
allows us to gain and maintain our
initiative as the enemy is forced to
react to our actions it can also
temporarily undermine the enemy's will
to resist when he is at his weakened
weakest while we continue to press the
attack
or initiative so I would say this when
it comes to its because it because
obviously trapping and destroying it
from a leadership perspective has a bad
connotation so what am I trying to do by
by trapping
someone in a conversation well this is a
very very simple very simple tactic that
I use all the time by trapping someone
if I'd say for you and I having a
conversation about something and I trap
you when I trap you my purpose isn't to
prove that I'm right the way I trap you
in the way that I win in a leadership
situation is when I trap you what
happens is I force you to come to the
conclusion yourself and you see it and
that's when I win so you end up walking
away from me saying you know chuckling
this is the way we should do it and what
you're telling me is what I wanted you
to say I got you to come up with the
idea that I wanted you to come up with
and I and if it's done correctly I
figured that out
eirick okay I had this wrong I
recognized that yes and where that
actually comes from is you not wanting
to win it's you wanting me to win there
comes from you not wanting to beat me is
like because you could beat me and I won
and that's it can make but actually what
you want is you want me to figure that
out
not that I walked away and go Chaco beat
me it said I feel like oh I see this
differently so next time I do it in the
right way and it comes from you actually
wanting to be successful so when we're
going at our folks and we if we have
these conversations and really what
we're trying to get them to do is
recognize it themselves it's not for the
satisfaction of being right it's for
them to get better and learn and evolve
and feel like they can go do it better
which is what I really want this for
them to go do it the right way and by
the way the way that you approach that
most effectively is to go in with that
attitude yourself I don't go in thinking
well Dave's got a bad plan so I'm gonna
get him to believe in my plan yeah
actually I go in there thinking maybe I
have a bad plan maybe Dave's plan is
better let's find out yeah and as we
explore that guess what if we could have
a civilized ego remove
conversation that plan will Pirkle the
good plan the correct plan will
percolate to the surface yeah and that
is what we're looking for and think of
the power of the times where if you were
in the leadership position where you
actually have that conversation and then
right you know what their plan is
actually better than mine because what
you don't have is now the conversation
with Jocko I don't know what's gonna
happen but eventually he's gonna win I'm
gonna be proved that he's smarter than
me and sooner or later it's actually not
effective anymore either because I've
just come to realize this guy he's
always got some answer he's always got
some final thing that makes him right
and I almost kind of resigned myself to
that but if if every snot not not by
design but because it actually you
actually are humble enough to see and go
you know I do not I didn't I didn't see
that that's a really interesting let's
do that go go go down that road go down
that road and I'll back you up
and if that happens often enough that I
feel like these conversations aren't a
contest over right this come the
conversation is actually how we both get
to the right place
and look if you're more experienced
you've done it more you probably are
going to be right more often but not all
the time and you're not trying to break
their will of here comes another card
guess what's gonna happen if I do I'm
gonna lose again and all that that that
idea of breaking someone's will when I
try and break your will the that my my
I'm being driven by my own insecurities
I want to prove to you that I'm right
that you're wrong that my plan is better
than your plan
I am completely being driven by my own
insecurities the person that is secure
and is actually confident and and
understands that they're in a good spot
and understands that it's okay like if
if if I make a mistake that I'm not it's
not the end of the world and I'm a human
and I'm not trying to portray the fact
that I'm not a human it's like okay if
we can get there if I can get there then
guess what if you come up with a better
plan that's awesome I think their plan
is better let's go with it
yeah the for the leaders out there
listening to this the humility
it requires to do that is actually your
your that's your biggest tool because
more often than not these situations are
a superior and a subordinate and you
know who knows who's the superior
everybody in the conversation I write
your performance review I write your
paycheck I do all I have all this
organizational influence that I can
exert over you I know that and the
subordinate knows that and if I'm
leveraging that to be right in the
conversation eventually unless the
subordinate just wants to get fired he's
gonna he's gonna give in but if I have
all those positional advantages and I
still come in with the humility and
reckon that's a really good idea I
didn't see that and I push that down to
you and we go run with your plan the
leadership capital you the deposit into
the bank of leadership you have it's
yeah and if you think if you think in
the back of your head that you can
effectively cover up your insecurities
to your subordinates through punitive
measures and through exalting your
authority over other human beings if
that's a fantasy in your head here is so
wrong your insecurities stand out in in
in fluorescent colors they stand out
like Curt Lee's vest in the Chosin
Reservoir battle fluorescent orange and
you might as well put a label on your
forehead that says I'm super insecure
that's why I'm trying to force my will
upon you because I'm scared and I'm
insecure yeah if you think that you can
cover that up you are so wrong so don't
a good example of trapping from the
Vietnam conflict occurred during
Operation Dewey Canyon North Vietnamese
activity along the Louis the Louis South
Vietnamese border increased dramatically
in early January 1969 large enemy
convoys including armored vehicles
regularly traveled from Laos
into South Vietnam
threatening friendly units and the SOG
boys weren't there tracking it
Colonel Robert H Baro and his 9th
Marines responded with operation Dewey
Canyon three battalions of ninth
Regiment crossed the dock wrong river on
february 11th and 12th the 3rd and 1st
battalions moved south southeast through
the mountainous terrain towards laos 2nd
battalion to the west swung south
southwest turning east astride the
vietnam laos border the north vietnamese
forces moving along route 922 from laos
into the A Shau Valley we've heard that
before or trapped between the three
battalions the North Vietnamese were
mauled as a result their equipment
losses were staggering more importantly
operation de Canyon destroyed a North
Vietnamese base area and so disrupted
their logistics that have forced them to
a bend abandon their planned spring
offensive in I Corps area developing an
ambush mentality perhaps the most common
tactical tool for gaining advantage is
the ambush all Marines are familiar with
an ambush as the type of combat patrol
in maneuver warfare ambush takes on a
much broader meaning and the development
of ambush mentality is integral to
maneuver warfare tactics the ambush
mentality is not new to most of us we
may have employed the ambush mentality
in sports in football the trap block as
an ambush a player pulls an offensive
lineman off line leaving a hole when a
defender comes through the whole another
lineman suddenly blocks him from the
side usually knocking him down the
players have blindsided him that is the
ambush mentality and in basketball
setting a pick is an ambush as one team
member drives to the basket and other
steps into the defenders path from
behind blocks the path stops the defense
and momentarily clears the lane to the
basket for the other team member again
that is the ambush mentality in combat
we move our reinforced squad into
position along a well-traveled trail we
position flank security to protect
ourselves and give identification and
warning of the enemy movements down the
trail we position our weapons so as to
concentrate our fires into a kill zone -
and to seal off exits forcing the enemy
to remain subject to our fires this
squad in the squad waits in position
until signaled when
immediately respond with concentrated
sustained fires on enemy forces trapped
in the Killzone the enemy surprised into
inaction unsure of what to do or where
to move is annihilated fires are
maintained until all the enemy are
killed or until signaled to stop the
that is the ambush mentality pretty
straightforward unless you're a SOG guy
and then you set your claymores up in
such a method and you put a a block of
c-4 that will stun the person right in
the ambush because was it Lin black I
think it was Lin black that blew himself
up over and over again until he found
out how much c4 it took to knock him out
right do you get any more legit than
that yeah no you don't the ambush
mentality tries to turn every situation
into an ambush I like that the ambush
into an ambush in this broader context
an ambush has several distinct features
first in an ambush we try to surprise
the enemy think of a patrol that we
ambush our enemies are walking through
the woods when suddenly I don't know
where they are under fire from multiple
directions they are taking heavy
casualties the psychological impact of a
surprise may paralyze their thoughts and
actions leaving them incapable of
reacting effectively to have an ambush
mentality means we always try to
surprise the enemy to do the unexpected
surprise is the rule rather than
exception rather than the exception
second we want to draw our enemy
unknowingly into a trap this will often
involve deceiving him we make one course
of action appear inviting when he takes
that course of action we are waiting for
him 3rd and ambushes invisible if the
ambush is not invisible it ceases to be
an ambush since then becomes a target
for the enemy whether we are defending
or attacking the enemy must not detect
us until it is too late for him to react
surprise often depends upon invisibility
that invisibility may be provided
through stealth and movement or focusing
the enemy's attention elsewhere to allow
our forces to maneuver without detection
you know the big coming home from Ramadi
what I I broke this down into offensive
versus defensive mentality but hey we
want to be an office and I would ask
these young junior officers that would
be coming through the officer training
course that Lafe was running at the time
I'd say hey is a direct action mission
unoffensive mission of course they'd all
say yeah and I'd say ok it takes us and
this was direct action mission takes us
an hour to get to the target and then we
spend 20 minutes on the target we blast
the door open we clear the target and it
takes an hour to get back you know
patrol and then Humvees know we're back
how much of that time was offensive and
then the guys think about it the sharp
ones would say three minutes and they'd
be right because while you're patrolling
guess what you're waiting to get
ambushed and and believe me this is when
we got to Ramadi I did not like the idea
of us waiting to get ambushed and of
course you can't avoid him you have to
go on Patrol you have to get sure you
have to move through the city but I
couldn't
what I didn't like was the ratio of hey
you know two hours of patrolling three
minutes of offense I didn't like that
ratio I liked the ratio of an hour
patrolling 24 hours on offense and then
another hour that's what I like and
that's kind of what we shift to do yeah
cuz the hour of patrolling is rook you
have to get there so you have to do that
that amount of time to get where you're
going whatever that amount of time is
you have to do that and you are
undeniably especially in Ramadi you were
exposed no matter how much firepower
you're bringing or how much you're
bringing to that and it requires very
little of the enemy to disrupt and do
very little it was easiest for them when
we were doing that and if you're gonna
make that investment in that time and
that commitment to doing that spend as
much time as you possibly can taking
advantage of whatever it is you've
created by going through that work in
doing that and all the stuff I'm hearing
you know stealth there's all these
things that I'm hearing in the ambush
should be the goal every time your goal
should be to keep the enemy from not
understanding what's happening all the
time it will just get why would you ever
do the frontal assault
they see it's coming now you still may
win on the frontal assault but it gives
the enemy every possible thing it could
have to defend itself against it they
see it coming they know it's coming your
mass in their firepower the frontal
assault nine times out of ten is a loser
even if you actually win the engagement
just a loser and you think like the
mindset should always be outmaneuver
them yes and and you it it it's when you
hear it it sounds so simple and when you
hear it in a business context in the
leadership context it sounds it sounds
that people echo brings up this example
of well that's just the way I am a you
know and what I hear from from leaders
off you know you know it I gotta have a
direct conversation with this person to
tell them what's going on look I get it
that sometimes there's an occasional
point yeah but most of the time there's
a way to maneuver that's gonna make that
whole situation infinitely better then
you're a direct assault on their brain
totally and and probably the biggest
thing that we need that I talk about and
I try to explain and dispel the myth
look when we're talking about flanking
your enemies in combat you are actually
talking about maneuvering to destroy
them to get into position to wipe them
out and if you're taking the analogy of
I have someone I work with
this is a peer this is my boss this is a
cow this is someone on my team the
flanking and the outmaneuvering isn't to
destroy them it's to get to a place for
them to recognize there's a better way
for me to do it that actually helps him
helps me helps a team and so my life
gets better and that frontal assault
even if it's well intended prevents that
from happening because the recipient
can't actually hear what you're trying
to get across which was the better way
cuz he's defensive and and you're
putting him in so even if the frontal
assault makes sense in your mind because
you have this totally outside all your
information is right and he's and it
seems so clear you're still dealing with
another human being who most of the time
simply doesn't want to hear it yeah and
is gonna get defense and is gonna attack
you back yes and or dig in harder and
make expend ammunition and we get a
worse relationship there's two things I
kinda have to say because I just I've
said this before but because I just got
asked this and I was kind of talking
through the exact scenario that we're
talking through with the company and you
know isn't that you know the rent the
hand went up in the back of the room
isn't that just manipulation and and
it's like well let me tell you what I
think the difference between leadership
and manipulation is because they both
use the same tools manipulation is when
I'm doing what I'm doing to benefit me
leadership is when I'm doing what I'm
doing I'm trying to get you to do what
you're doing I'm trying to get you to do
what I want you to do because it's gonna
benefit you and it's gonna benefit the
team and you you threw this out there
you said it's gonna be it's gonna make
my life better but what you really mean
is it's gonna make our life better
the team's life better and most
important so I've actually want when I
manipulate you Dave Burke I'm
manipulating you and everything that I'm
doing every maneuver that I'm making
happen to you I'm doing it and it's
gonna benefit you're like way over they
for sure way over me and when you look
up you pride in my in my best my best
manipulation that I can do you don't
even realize that it happened and you're
looking up going like did a good job on
that last you know project that I had to
do I did a super job and oh and I got a
fat you know paycheck and a bonus and
and oh that's great I did great and
that's exactly what I want you to be
saying I want you to be saying I did
great yeah and you know what
subconsciously in the back of that
little nugget of a brain you got in
there you're going on
that guy kind of helped me out that yeah
who's that boss man 100% and that's what
we want because then they realize our
team realizes that we care about the
team or do we care about ourselves and
then when we have that that's that's the
trust and the relationship and that's
what makes a team strong that is the
glue that makes the team strong you if
you don't trust me and I don't trust you
we don't have a team Perry there's no
glue soon as soon as that thing as soon
as that pressure comes along we're gonna
fracture gonna fall apart
when we have a strong bond we know what
that pressure does to us it makes it
even stronger get some back to the book
the reverse slope defenses an example of
using invisibility to spring an ambush
the enemy does not know where you are
until he comes over the crest of a hill
and is hit by our fires his vehicles are
hit on their soft underbelly's his
troops are exposed to our weapons
because he could not see us into the
last moment he could not call in
artillery fire on our position the
reverse slope nominally protects us from
his direct fire it protects us from his
observation and thus his indirect fire
that is part of the ambush mentality do
not let yourself be seen forth in an
ambush we want to shock the enemy
instead of taking him under fire
gradually with a few weapons at
long-range we wait until he is within
easy range of us with every weapon we
then open up suddenly all at once with
everything we have he is paralyzed by
the shock he cannot react everything was
going fine and suddenly is in a
firestorm with people falling all around
him often he will panic making his
problem worse as he reacts
rather than acts combined-arms may be
used to ambush the enemy artillery raids
that reach deeper into his vital areas
than expected can produce the same
desired shock effect as ground-based
ambush we place him in a dilemma as he
attempts to move from the effects of
artillery and goes right into attack by
the air finally in the ambush mentality
we always focus on the enemy the purpose
of that ambush is not to hold a piece of
terrain just to destroy the enemy we
used terrain to affect for the ambush
but the terrain itself is not what we're
fighting for
all right next section asymmetry
fighting asymmetrically means gaining
advantage through imbalance applying
strength against enemy weakness fighting
asymmetrically means using dissimilar
techniques and capabilities to maximize
our own strengths while exploiting enemy
weaknesses
fighting asymmetrically means fighting
the enemy on your own
rather than on his by fighting
asymmetrically we do not have to be
numerically superior to defeat the enemy
we only have to be able to exploit his
vulnerabilities for example using tanks
to fight enemy tanks infantry to fight
enemy infantry and air to fight enemy
air is symmetrical using attack
helicopters to fight tanks and close air
support against enemy infantry are
examples of fighting asymmetrically in
these examples we gain advantage of the
greater speed and mobility of the
aircraft relative to the enemy ambushing
tanks with attack helicopters and
terrain which hampers tank maneuvers
provides an even more effective even
more effect and generates even more
advantage this is the the so important
for people to think about okay jujitsu
if we're going against a or fighting I
should say if you're going against a
boxer do you box them no you take them
down if you're going against a wrestler
what do you do you strike with them cuz
they're not used to striking if you're
going against the jujitsu person what do
you do you punch them you stay standing
you don't go in two persons what the
person's good at you don't want to fight
them in their own game if you watch the
early UFC's that's why everyone wants to
jujitsu because takedown you didn't see
horse bracy's standing in there and
trading blows no he went asymmetrical
that's what you do obviously it's what
you do on the battlefield when we get
into leadership when we get into
relationships if I've got someone that's
got a strong passionate idea about
something I am NOT going to attack that
idea with my passion and my strong
feeling because now we're all we're
doing is creating conflict between us
where this is not improving my position
it's actually strengthening their
position because they're digging in
deeper so what do I do I look for
another thing that I can start to
maneuver on get them thinking so often
so so often so so many of my solutions
for leadership is
initially as Crete is like us simply and
you've heard me saying this David say a
baba ba-ba-ba-ba and now you've started
a conversation because that's what I
want right because if I'm not in a
conversation with someone then there's
no possible way I can convince of
anything right if all I'm doing is
attacking them they're not going to
convinced of anything so I I do this
that the other thing and I make a couple
maneuvers and now I'm in a conversation
and the conversation probably has
nothing to do with this subject that I'm
eventually going to going to have change
their mind on you just got to build
trust
yes yet just trying to build a
relationship and build some trust and
you could be a hundred percent right and
they could be a hundred percent wrong
and if you attack them to prove that
point you you get nothing and you get no
trust and if I invite you actually do
get something you go backwards in your
relationship you go backwards that's
what's happening but if you completely
out maneuver in a different direction
and I just come to find that I can talk
to you I can have a relationship with
you I can communicate with you when you
do eventually circle back to the thing
that was sort of the initiation of the
conflict I'm actually gonna listen to
you
and that's what you okay I'll hear you
out and you're what you have to say and
you know P like Oh conflict avoidance
like the idea of conflict avoidance is
what you're really trying to do is are
you actually gonna be able to convince
the person of what's what's the best
thing in their world and the best
outcome that you're trying to get to
it's the idea of conflict avoidance it's
more the idea of is this person gonna
listen to me and if and if the person
won't listen to me and I move backwards
not not not only do I lose they lose too
they lose and you and we talked about
what what really what a leader really
wants us they care about their people
they want their people just what we'd
said you want their lives to be better
so do I need to take maybe it's gonna
take longer than I'd like it to take I'm
not gonna solve this today because I
have nothing no foundation to build on I
have to start with a conversation and go
from there yeah where do we end up
tactically when we engage in conflict
sure we're beating this dead horse
sure
we might win that conflict but where do
we end up strategically because we'd
oving to that conflict head-on we've
heard a trust refer a relationship
don't do it part of the reason we're
beating the dead horse though is it
happens all the time indeed indeed
here's the conclusion to that chapter
combat is a test of wills where the
object is to win one way to win is to
gain and exploit every possible
advantage this means using maneuver and
surprise whenever possible
it means employing complementary forces
and combined arms
it means exploiting the terrain weather
and times of darkness to our advantage
it means trapping our enemy by ambush or
by some other means it means fighting
asymmetrically to gain added advantage
this is what Sun Tzu meant when he wrote
therefore a skilled commander seeks
victory from the situation and does not
demand it of his subordinates yes and I
know you've heard me talk about
dictating the situation as opposed to
letting the situation dictate but what
kind of ownership are you taking as a
leader if you say you know what I'm I'm
gonna set this situation up in such a
way that that victory will come not from
not from my troops and what they do but
just by the situation I put them in
they're going to win that's that's
that's how much ownership I'm taking
over this situation we are going to win
because of the situation I put you in
will be guaranteed victory
that's a skilled commander
yes chapter four we're moving right
along almost two hours deep chapter four
is called being faster hit quickly hit
hard and keep right on hitting give the
enemy no rest no opportunity to
consolidate his forces and hit back at
you
that's Holland M Smith Howlin mad
four-star general he's the guy that's
called the father of amphibious warfare
fountain World War one and led task
force 56 in the Battle of a little
battle called the Iwo Jima and again
what's scary about reading quotes like
this hit quickly hit hard and keep right
on hitting give the enemy no rest no
opportunity to consolidate his forces
and hit back at you what is that to say
to someone that's predisposed to go on
the attack this is the quote they've
been waiting to hear you know you were
just talking about conflict avoidance
and the person that that thinks hey you
know what you're just trying to avoid
conflict Dave I'm gonna roll with
Holland Smith general Smith's outlook
which is I'm gonna hit hard and hit
quickly and I'm gonna keep right on
hitting you got to not be predisposed
for that yeah it doesn't say the front
it's it's not the frontal assault that's
not what he's saying
for the infantrymen to be truly
effective he will have to be as light of
foot as he is quick of thought mobility
is needed most in all classrooms so
there you go there's the counter there's
the dichotomy to Holland Smith's
mobility is needed most of all in a
clash of arms Swift and agile movement
plus rapidity and intelligent tactical
flexibility are it's true essentials
coming from John a English who is a
Canadian actually Canadian Army vet
known for his
military writings studies so here we go
into the chapter usually to think of
weapons means to think of a personal
rifle or pistol the unit's machine guns
and mortars or the aircraft's missiles
bombs or guns a logistician may realize
that weapons include trucks bulldozers
and excavators submarines overlook one
of their most powerful weapons one that
creates advantage for infantryman
aviators and logisticians equally that
weapon is speed speed in combat how is
speed a weapon think of sports again the
breakaway in hockey uses speed as a
weapon by rapidly passing the puck down
the ice one team denies the other the
chance to get set up on defense speed
circumvents their opponents ability to
respond in an organized manner the fast
break in basketball seeks the same
result in two or three passes the balls
down the court and the basket is scored
all before the opposition can react the
results of speed often reach beyond the
immediate goal how many times have we
seen a score a team score on a
fast-break steal a ball as it comes in
bounds immediately score again and even
a third time unable to regain their
composure that composure the victims of
the fast-break become the victims of a
rally the victims lose confidence passes
go astray signals become crossed tempers
flare arguments ensue the rally becomes
a rout the beleaguered players see
certain defeat they virtually give up
while still on the court and you know as
I was thinking about that section when
you if you watch basketball and like a
fast break and then another fast break
what does the coach do because the
timeouts right now we can't yeah hey
slow this thing down right now we're
gonna slow this thing down the same
thing can happen in combat the battalion
or fighter aircraft or load the lower
logistics train can consistently move
and act faster than its enemy as a
powerful an advantage the in June of
1943 during the Battle of Saipan the
aggressive hardening tactics of general
Holland Smith proved to be singularly
successful in defeating the Japanese
defenders general Smith's tactical plan
for Saipan called for applying
unremitting pressure on the enemy and
bypassing strong points of
resistance by mopping up by reserved
elements in order to press the attack to
better ground so there we have it there
we have it general Smith who we just
quoted general Smith who we just quoted
and what's he doing those hard points of
resistance
he's bypass yeah he's bypassing a long
indoctrinated with the value of speed in
an in amphibious operations general
Smith's bypassing tactics placed the
Japanese remaining the Japanese
remaining in their fixes add an extreme
tactical disadvantage these tactics
proved very effective in isolating and
reducing the Japanese Defense general
Smith's use of speed served as a force
multiplier and it also reduced marine
casualties the British Royal Air Force
bested the Germans during the Battle of
Britain in World War two in part because
they were able to speedily recover
recover their downed pilots returned
them to base place them in a new
aircraft and have them fighting again in
the afternoon down German pilots were
less easily easily recovered and the
Luftwaffe had fewer of the long-range
aircraft required for replacement
eventually pilot and aircraft losses
forced the Germans to end daylight
bombing and resort strictly to
relatively ineffective night attacks
yeah the the Brits were getting shot
down overwritten right or at least close
to Britain yes and speed doesn't just
mean my plane is faster than yours in
this case it's that operational tempo
speed of how quickly can I get my guys
back into an airplane and and that was a
huge advantage that they had because
every time an airplane got shot down
they literally just got in a trunk and
drove back to base that's kind of crazy
right like you get shot down and then
they're just bringing you back to base
but you another aircraft you're gonna go
get some more yep the Brits are hard
race of people resilient man yeah being
out there on that island yeah attacked
by the Nazi war machine whatever bring
it bring it great leaders have
repeatedly stated the value of speed in
combat Napoleon said I'm Napoleon said I
may lose in battle but I shall never
lose
a minute I may lose him battle but I
shall never lose a minute
Nathan Bedford Forrest told his secret
of many victories get there first with
the most men General Patton said in 1943
when the great day of battle comes
remember your training and remember
above all else that speed and violence
of attack are the sure road to success
history's great commander commanders
differed in many ways but one thing they
shared was a sense of the importance of
speed in operation urgent fury 1983 the
battalion the Marines of battalion
landing team to eight moved fast as
their commander Lieutenant Colonel Ray
Smith had trained them to do when they
captured the operations officer of the
Grenadian army he said to them you
appeared so swiftly in so many places
where we didn't expect you that it was
clear that resistance was hopeless so I
recommended to my superiors that we lay
down our arms and go into hiding that is
what speed used as a weapon can do for
you
what is speed what is speed would seem
to have a simple answer speed is going
fast this is speed we think of when
driving a car more miles per hour that's
part of the answer that is part of the
answer in tactics as well we use speed
to gain initiative and advantage over
the enemy like you just talked about
planes faster for example when a Tank
Battalion attacks that goes over ground
as fast as it can
general bulk asked whether the Russian
tanks ever used terrain in their attacks
against him during World War two he
replied that they had used terrain on
occasion but more often they used speed
the question followed up which was
harder to defend against bulk answered
speed physical speed moving more miles
per hour as a powerful weapon in itself
on our approach to the enemy speed and
movement reduces rudia reaction time
when we were going through him and
around him it changes the situation
faster than he can react once we are
past him it makes his reaction
irrelevant in all three cases speed
impacts on the enemy especially his mind
causing fear indecision and helplessness
remember attacking the enemy's mind is a
central tenant
maneuver warfare I might even call it
the primary diner yeah speed and time in
a military sense there is more to speed
than simply going fast and there is a
vital difference between acting rapidly
and acting recklessly there's a
dichotomy coming at you live from Marine
Corps one TAC three with time we must
always consider the closely related
factor of timing speed and time are
closely related in fact speed is defined
in terms of time miles or kilometers per
hour in tactics what this means is
always of the utmost importance time
cannot be spent in action must be spent
thinking about how to act effectively
time that cannot be spent in actions if
you can't go what you need to do is
spend that time thinking about how
you're gonna act effectively I wonder
how much Modern Life has chewed up that
idea because when we're not thinking
when we we can we we can't do something
I see people all the time they're not
they're not being proactive
I do not anything yeah they're not doing
anything productive I'm thinking of
they're definitely not thinking about
how to act when they can't act they're
not thinking about how to act
effectively no for sure
I see that all the time I was on a
flight coming home if I'd 6-hour flight
from a client of Jersey back to San
Diego yeah and look six hours in a plane
for me is a godsend because I got
basically no distraction I got my laptop
and I'm hammered I'm working I'm
cranking out I don't know who it was cuz
I didn't see him but the seat over and
up one guy watched a movie on the plane
and I come he saw and I saw the movie I
don't know the movie was when the movie
ended he replayed the same movie again
yeah and I'm thinking man I don't know
what what he's doing and look take a nap
or something kind of refresh and then
get to get back in the game but I see it
my kids I mean their natural state is to
do nothing productive and you actually
have to rent like if you're not doing if
you're not physically doing something
you need to be mentally doing something
right then to think about what is my
next move what am I going to do after
this
yeah and like you just said because I'm
sure they'll be pushback on that comment
sometimes you do have to and I've talked
about this before I've gone on a plane
and been like I'm done I'm done I'm then
my brain is fried I need to watch the
dumbest movie I can watch and rack out
and in fact I sleep on planes
beautifully
I can sleep on planes beautifully if you
see me on a plane guess what I probably
got up at 2 o'clock in the morning had a
workout and before I got on that plane
I'm gonna go to sleep come talk to me
when we land
but yes how much time so yeah you might
need a little break here and there for
sure and by the way how long does it
take to mentally recover is this a
five-hour evolution it's like reset and
take two you don't intentionally take a
little bit of a breather and then get
back in the game
back to the book even when we are
engaged with the enemy
we are not always moving fast to some of
the time we are not moving at all
nonetheless every moment nonetheless
every moment is still of the utmost
importance even when we're sitting still
a battalion staff that takes a day to
plan an action is obviously slower than
one that takes an hour a tank battalion
that takes three hours to refuel is
slower than one that takes two hours
just as one that must refuel every
hundred miles is slower than one that
must refuel every 200 a company that
sits down to eat once it is taken the
objective is slower than the company
that presses on deeper into the enemy a
fighter squadron that can fly only three
sorties per aircraft per day is slower
in terms of effect on the enemy than one
two five six a maintenance repair team
that can takes two days to fix the
damaged vehicle and get it back into
action is slow in terms of fact on the
enemy then one that can do it overnight
every moment is still of utmost
important making maximum use of every
hour and every minute is is important to
speed in combat as simply going fast
when we are moving this is important to
remember every is important to every
member of a military force whether
serving on staffs in units aviation
combat service support ground everyone
a good tactician has a constant sense of
urgency we feel guilty if we are idle we
never waste time and we are never
content with the pace at which things
are happening we are always saying to
ourselves and others faster faster
we know that if speed is a weapon so is
time and that is so legit think about a
leader who can cultivate that mindset in
all of his people think about how
productive your people are if they all
feel like every single thing they do
whether they're the the the most the the
person that seems like okay where's
sales be his business so I'm in sale the
people that are on the back end and that
get no publicity that are working the
logistics with the administration think
about it the leader that gets everybody
in his organization to feel that same
thing that if I'm wasting time the guilt
of hurting the team if you can cultivate
that from everyone not just your your
point of attack people but everybody
think about what those organizations are
able to do you and I were with a client
and we were talking about this and one
of the problems that this particular
client had was they felt like they
couldn't create a sense of urgency in
their organization
so like you're saying some people had it
at the point they said how do we create
a sense of urgency so for those of you
that are wondering how to create a sense
of urgency with your people the way that
you do it is by making sure they
understand why they're doing what
they're doing and why it's important and
the example that I gave was if you have
a seal platoon and and I would see this
situation unfold in training exercise
you've got a seal platoon and they've
got a perimeter set up meaning there's
stagnant they're maybe they're doing a
reorganization of ammunition maybe
they're getting a headcount maybe they
are working on a wounded guy or
something like that so they're in a
stagnant position they've got their 360
degree security set up and all of a
sudden someone sees enemy maneuvering on
them and now the leader wants to create
a sense of her
wants to leave so he says alright
everyone hey we're moving we're leaving
in one minute pack up your stuff we're
leaving in one minute and guys you know
someone guys like hey man we just got
here I'm tired I'm just trying to sort
out my ammunition someone's out saying
hey we got this wounded guy he's
unstable I need to get him stabilized
and someone else is saying well hey
we're trying to still get a full head
count over here you know let me let me
just get a get of handle my fireteam
that's what they're all thinking and and
maybe some of those priorities are
actually really really important
certainly we have a wounded guy
certainly we want to know where our
people are but and those people so they
don't really do anything they don't
react his one-minute call gets blown off
and you don't think this happens in the
military all it happens I see it happen
over and over and over and over again
that steel platoon commander can
understand why no one will move and so
he says it again hey everyone will leave
and we'll even in 30 seconds and what
happens
say everyone thinks the same thing they
just thought 30 seconds ago which is I'm
not going anywhere I got this I got my
gear out I'm sort and ammunition hit
calm down the lieutenant's freaking out
again
why can't he create a sense of urgency
the reason he's not effectively creating
a sense of urgency is because he's not
explaining to his people why they need
to move so when he says when a good
leader says hey everyone guess what I
know we're jumbled up right now we have
enemy maneuvering to the high ground on
our flank there 200 meters away we need
to move right now or we're gonna get
slaughtered and you'll see people move
so when you want to create that sense of
urgency see when you want to get people
to understand the importance of time and
that we never waste time and that we
feel guilty for that word if we're idle
and then we have a constant sense of
urgency if you want to make that happen
explain to your people why they're doing
what they're doing and why agency and
speed is important in that particular
situation
timing we employ speed and use time to
create tempo tempo is not merely a
matter of acting fastest or acting at
the earliest opportunity it is also a
matter of timing acting at the right
time
timing requires an appreciation for the
rhythm of combats so we can exploit that
rhythm to our advantage is physically
impossible to always operate at peak
tempo like we just talked about
sometimes you got to take a breather
sometimes you got to watch the big
lebowski for the 174th time even though
we can extend operating cycles through
the economical reuse of resources we
cannot operate at top speed indefinitely
we must rest our people and replenish
our supplies the test of skill is to be
able to generate and maintain a fast
pace when the situation calls for it and
to recover when it will not hurt us
timing means knowing when to act and
equally important when not to act you
gotta know when you can take a little
breather
although speed is important tactical
weapon there are situations in which it
is better to bide our time so here we go
here's the dichotomy here's the
dichotomy speed is an important tactical
weapon there are situation in which it
is better to bide our time if our
concept of operation involves a
diversion we need to allow time for the
diversion to take effect if we have laid
and an ambush for the enemy we need to
give the enemy time to fall fully into
the trap if the situation is still
forming we may not we may want to
develop it further before we commit to a
course of action so this is a big one
that see this happened with the young
seals where they would immediately make
a decision from before and we would
actually say to him say hey we gotta let
the situation develop those are the
words that we would use let the
situation develop and sometimes you have
to do that and there's that dichotomy
that you've go too far in one direction
you're gonna get overrun for example an
error commonly made by defenders is
counter attacking shoot too soon so that
the enemy is merely pushed back rather
than cut off and circled and destroy
decisive action is our goal and it must
be time to occur at the proper moment
there are times to act and there are
times to set the stage and wait so
strategic you're talking about that yeah
we talk about all the time and that
strategic patience of hey you have to
let the situation develops you you
actually get more understanding of
what's happening so the move that you do
make is the right move and when you're
talking about your folks you do not not
be able to run at the highest up tempo
all the time you know especially if we
work with these younger companies
startups that are that are growing and
your folks aren't always going to tell
you either they're not gonna say hey I
think we need to take a knee or or I
think we need to reevaluate their heads
down and go and they're gonna go and go
and go and and actually your job as a
leader is to recognize when that is when
they're not telling you that we need
yeah I mean I always had that problem
but I personally always had that problem
because no one wanted to tell me hey we
need to break yeah like you know how
many times
Lafe babban came up to me and said hey
man I could really use it breather or
Jeep he came up to me and said hey hey
boss I gotta get some downtime zero
amount of x JP said that to me is zero
it's zero so and other times when he
absolutely needs downtime oh yeah cuz he
would burn the candle at both ends is
intere he's gonna go get some so yes as
a leader you need to be able to
recognize those things because they're
not always gonna say it to you a benefit
from a decision not to act is that it
saves precious resources and energy for
later commitment some leaders dis
dissipate their units energy on constant
unpriced activity not all not all
activities support the mission a units
energy is not easily replenished and
should be treated as a precious resource
to be expended only toward decisive
goals relative speed going fast and
making efficient use of time are both
parts of the answer to the question what
is speed however something else must be
considered the enemy
as with all things in war speed is
relative speed is meaningful militarily
only if we are acting faster than the
enemy we can do that either by slowing
the enemy or by increasing our own speed
in the battle for the Falkland Islands
in 1982 the British Army moved slowly
the terrain was difficult the weather
was abominable and much the material had
to be moved on the men's backs all of
which slowed down the British
nevertheless the British still had the
advantage in speed because they moved
faster than the Argentine's who once
they had made their initial dispositions
essentially did not move that
superiority and relative speed allowed
the British to maintain the initiative
throughout the campaign covered that one
on the podcast brutal continuing speed
to be consistent superiority in relative
speed must continue over time it is not
enough to move faster only faster than
the enemy only now and then because
we're not moving faster the advantage
the initiative passed if it passes to
him most forces can manage an
intermittent bursts of speed but must
then halt for a considerable period to
recover between bursts during that whole
they are likely to lose their advantage
we realize that we cannot operate a full
speed indefinitely and the challenge is
to be consistently faster than the enemy
one way to sustain speed is to use the
effects of combined arms when the
infantry are mounted troops must break
contact temporarily to maneuver resupply
or recover air and artillery can keep
the pressure on maneuver cannot be
sustained indefinitely but the momentum
can be maintained through skillful
planning combined on defects keeping the
enemy always at a disadvantage here the
speed of logistics become critical
although physical exhaustion is a factor
halts often are driven by logistics
ground or aviation units must stop for
equipment repair maintenance and
resupply supporting forces can minimize
loss of speed if they deliver the
supplies and perform maintenance quickly
thus they enable combat units to move
before the enemy gains the initiative I
get paranoid about the enemy like I'm
always thinking that then if I'm not
moving
there they are they're maneuvering for
sure and every company should think like
that yes and we're talking about sort of
the differences between combat and the
differences between the private sector
and business we work with companies that
are one of the challenges that are
facing is they have competitors you know
if strong competitors and they're trying
to carve out more market share or
they're trying to enter a geographic
region that maybe they don't have a
foothold in and they want to move into
there and to expand their business and
we talked about what what they want with
in regard to the competition and the
things that they say are things like we
want to annihilate them I mean they're
working in the competition in the
private sector is it is fierce and when
they're talking about they want to run
you out of business I mean it is
legitimate competition that are talking
about here not that we're gonna find a
natural way to share they want to run
you down and I think the private said
they recognize that and if you're not
maneuvering into that space your
competition is and their goal is to bury
you that's really what their goal is and
we in the private sector when we see
companies that are slow on that and hey
I want we want to wait and kind of see
how this and their enemies maneuvering
into that space even if their first
maneuver into that space isn't ideal
they're in there and they have a
foothold and your ability to get that
back as almost zero if they get out in
front of you there and make no mistake
it combat up they're trying to kill you
they're trying to run you over and that
is hard core to recognize that if you're
not doing it they are yeah and and we
work with companies
it's what's interesting and what's cool
is you know as American military people
we always were the biggest and the
strongest and the most powerful right
but what's cool about echelon front is
that we work with like I'll be working
with one company that's the the
insurgent yeah and then we'll the next
day I'll be working with a company that
is the absolute powerhouse yes and guess
what there's advantages and
disadvantages that insurgent can
maneuver quickly and make changes and
disrupt the
the big person can overpower and destroy
so you get we get to see that all the
time yeah both sides but on both those
sides the one that is paranoid the one
that is thinking you know what I'm an
insurgent if I don't give I don't attack
that big company they're gonna put me
under I'm not gonna let it happen the
those are the ones that step up the big
companies that say oh you know what
those insurgents right there they could
take a part of our business and that
could turn into a total rout for us and
I will not allow that to happen we will
destroy them we get to work with both
both sides and the ones that have that
attitude yeah are the ones that end up
winning a really big really historically
successful company that has done great
work and and had year after year of good
work that is paranoid of that those
companies are hard to take down because
they've got all those tangible things
and they had that mindset of what got us
here doesn't guarantee that we get it
tomorrow
and when you see a good company that
wants to get better and they are
paranoid of the insurgency that they
used to be five you those are the ones
that fight off the complacency that
fight off the ego hey we've arrived
we've accomplished our objective and
when you got a big company that doesn't
that is paranoid of losing or a man it's
it's awesome to see and that requires
humble leadership saying hey there are
no guarantees tomorrow these guys are
out to get us
yeah that's legit yeah that's a tough
feeling it's a it's a tough feeling to
live with and I say that speaking from
personal experience like you know what
I've know I've told you and the team
that's like hey you guys want to know
why I don't sleep because I'm paranoid
of what's gonna happen we need to bring
our a-game every day the day that we
stake a step back the day that we're not
putting putting forth absolute best is
the day someone else out there's gonna
get a little foothold I will not allow
that to happen it will not happen
because we're on the warpath over here
amen and forever leak for every leader
that has that feeling about their
those leaders you want that for someone
like me to come into a shell on Front
how about Dave Burke's the reason this
company failed how about we brought in
this guy who didn't he didn't stay on
the path to hold how about Dave got
complacent and I start that feeling of
paranoia
there is no way I'm gonna contribute to
this company not being successful and if
you get those leaders had have created
something and built something and they
have that same feeling of ownership all
the way down to the bottom or the most
junior person the most mute the newest
hires is paranoid and they are in the
game that's a that force is so powerful
and it's the cult and the way they do
that if you're is to give them that same
amount of in that same ownership you
have of this is yours and oh by the way
that means we are we can all lose here
you have to feel that same feeling of I
I could be the reason we fail and I am
NOT going to let that happen and that's
a that's a burden that that does that
that that's a burden yeah that's a
feeling that stays with you and it stays
and if you don't have that feeling
there's something wrong did you get it
here anyway yeah if you're in the wrong
you're doing something wrong if you
don't have that feeling you know speed
and change in order to act consistently
faster the consistently act faster than
the enemy it is necessary to do more
than move quickly it is also necessary
to make rapid transitions from one
action to another while there are many
types of transitions in combat it's
important to remember that the
transition transitions produce friction
reduction of friction minimizes the loss
of tempo that the friction generates at
the point of transition a unit that can
make transitions faster and more
smoothly than another can be said to
have greater relative speed in jujitsu I
know that I learned one of the one of
the really powerful lessons that I
learned I learned from watching my old
coach Fabio Santos I was watching him
train this is when I was probably a
white belt or a blue belt but I was
watching him train with one of the you
know one of his purple belts or one of
our purple belts that we had at the time
and I was watching him and like for
instance as the guy mounted him as the
guy mounted him he was escaping as the
guy put him the guard he was passing the
guard so he did not allow he was just
ahead on tempo he was just just slightly
ahead like I'm not waiting for you to
settle in position no it's not happening
I'm actually going right now so that is
a good attitude to have in everything in
the 18th century the importance of fast
transitions sometimes called agility was
displayed when shifting from column
formation into line if an army could not
rapidly deploy into line and
consequently consequently was engaged
while still in column it was often
beaten much drill is devoted to
practicing this difficult transition so
it could be accomplished rapidly in
combat today we develop proficiencies in
battle drills and immediate action
drills that allow units to rapidly
transition from one formation to another
without pausing it is important to be it
is important to be able to affect rapid
changes in organization as well being
quick to affect required changes in task
organization based on a rapidly changing
battle situation increases agility and
decreases reaction times battle drills
and rehearsals can be conducted to
smooth out procedures for changing
organization rapidly the the faster
these transitions can be made the more
effective the force becomes the place in
time and space where transitions occur
can be called a friction point friction
points commonly encountered in tactics
include movement from an assembly area
to attack from Patrol movement formation
to ambush posture from defensive posture
to attack from one manoeuvre to another
and so forth the transition involves
simply positional changes and drills but
also changes of attitude in the minds of
Marines we must shift our mental focus
from one movement to another so here's
here's one of the things that I did with
my platoons with my task units
was super effective when it came time to
do an assault and and some guys would
really set up a specialized assault
formation okay since we're doing a solo
key we're gonna put the widow they would
make these changes to their formation
and I would minimize really minimize if
not completely eliminate this whole
change in the way we're gonna form so
we're gonna do an assault okay cool
charlie platoon you're on assault and
you got one squad from Delta everyone's
in the same same patrol formation
everything is the same but you but
figuring to do the assault okay cool
I'm not saying okay we're gonna take
these breaches and were to put these
with we're to set up these special over
no no no everything's the same and by
the way what happens when we get hit and
you know things start falling apart
everyone's with the unit the little
element that they were used to working
with and we're we got unit integrity all
the time
that being said because you can't
guarantee that I would always rehearse
and train like we've got on the beach
and do real battle drills where I'd call
all these different maneuvers rapidly in
succession on top of one another haven't
be all confused and all jumbled up and
you had to just figure it out and make
it happen
so we got on the battlefield we would
never get it jungle dug on the
battlefield as we would when I was
running blender drills what we call them
blender drills on a on my platoons like
we drunk the under drills no one it be
just every maybe every person would be
in a different position so everyone got
used to okay what do you do what's the
protocol that you do when you're all
jumbled up here's the protocol you look
around if you look around and there's no
one making a call grab four guys you're
a fireteam leader make something happen
go yeah so between those two things
between being ready for the chaos and
the disorganization because we train
that way and always to the best of the
the best that I could possibly pull it
off hey we're gonna keep our normal
formations like when this talks about
patrol formation ambush posture
defensive posture all those postures for
me in my tasking it in my seal platoon
they were the same there's no confusion
like this is what's happening
would you have to would you have to take
a little snipe realm and pull on her
you'd have to do something Cajun ik s
yeah but I would do that as little as
possible
and I would train to the point that they
could handle it if it happened but the
thing is it just wouldn't happen when
you're that when you're that used to
being in that position so the weird
thing about this is you might is this
gave us total freedom because we could
assault from a totally different
direction I could say oh yeah by the way
that looks like it's a secure it looks
like there's a guard up there so we're
gonna go in from the other we're gonna
go in from the south and nothing changes
everyone's everyone's fine we're still
in put tune integrity this is just the
no changes so that's a little trick that
I used it was and I'm trying to think
imagine in my mind right now what the
driving force that makes people want to
specialize for a particular part of an
operation the reason that I think we
want to do it is because it seems from a
broad perspective no no from the
opposite of a prop from a granular
perspective if we've set up like this
that part of the operation will go
smoother and there's a chance that
they're right in that particular smooth
operation where nothing goes wrong but
in any other thing when anything goes
sideways it's not the right answer and
if you actually take the mindset that
nothing is ever gonna happen the way
that you plan it to happen if you just
accept that which I think was verbatim
out of the beginning of this is your
plan is not gonna go the way that you
think you immediately recognize that
that's that's not a good plan and it
doesn't mean everybody needs to be an
expert in every single thing that
sampling means but it means everybody
and you talked about the transitions you
everybody has to have the flexibility
and then recognize you talked about a
protocol okay I can't answer what we're
going to do and I'll but I know there's
a protocol this is what we're gonna do
the four of us we're gonna go and we're
gonna go attack that problem that
problem will reveal itself as we move
down it but the hey imma imma I don't I
don't do that mission I'm at this guy
mission well I'm I'm really sorry but we
haven't chosen to do this mission
because the enemy is now doing
something totally different so the
alternative is to sit here and do
nothing or that we can get up and
actually transition out of this mindset
you know the defense to offense all
those things that's all mindset people
actually can get good at that but
through through doing it over and over
again they can actually get get good at
that you remember what you're saying
earlier about the stealth fighter about
how you used even though you had this
stealth fighter and you had all this
advantage
you still like did the fundamental
things correctly and that's exactly what
I did
so I would have my guys trained up where
it didn't matter what person from te you
take four guys from tu bruiser five guys
from T Bruce one of them was gonna step
up as a fireteam leader and start making
something happen that's the way it was
gonna be so I had the capability really
to mix and match people and set up at a
target assault however I wanted to but
even though I had that step you know
that capability that that advanced
capability that I could scramble
everyone up and we could be effective it
didn't matter I still used the
fundamental principle to be as simple as
possible because simplicity is is
paramount yes back to the book a modern
example of the importance of fast
transitions comes from aerial combat
good deal Dave Burke is in the house in
the Korean War American aviators
achieved this is the part of the book
where you just waiting to get here
American aviator aviators achieved a
high kill ratio of about 10 to 1 over
their North Korean and Chinese opponents
at first glance this is somewhat
surprising the main enemy fighter that
make 15 was superior to the American
f-86 in a number of key respects it
could climb and accelerate faster and it
had better sustained turn rate the f-86
however was superior to the make in too
critical though less obvious respects
first because it had high powered
hydraulic controls the f-86 could shift
from one manoeuvre to another faster
than the MiG second because of its
bubble canopy the f-86 had better
visibility the f-86 better field of view
provided better situational awareness
and also contributed to the fast
transitions because it allowed its pilot
understand changing situations more
quickly so the beauty of this example is
it's it's a literal example of those
transitions we were just talking about
and and I I briefed this and I actually
used this Korean War example of the f-86
and mig-15 I had totally forgotten it
was in this book completely forgotten
this example was used in the 1:3 and it
says almost the exact same thing the
connection I've made from this story of
my machine in your machine what your
machine does well and what my machine my
advantages and disadvantages all too
often we see what people want to do with
their disadvantages is hey we need
another machine this machine doesn't do
this as well so I want more resources
and I want more equipment and the answer
is hey we can't do that we if we could
it's gonna take us years to develop this
and they spent all this time thinking
about well if I only had a machine that
turned better and if I only had a thing
that Klein and they spent all this time
thinking about what it is that they
can't do instead of recognizing hey all
right what are our strengths what are
our advantages here and what do we need
to do to build a plan that leverages
those strengths you can actually
outperform people in a way that doesn't
seem to be evident to them if they
aren't what I got a better machine why
do I need to worry about my transitions
I do this better than you that's a huge
disadvantage for them that they don't
even realize and if you spend less time
worrying about hey what what what's
wrong with the things that I haven't
think we're my advantages what small
companies I don't have the revenue we
don't have the market chat we don't but
you know you have you've got twenty five
people you know quickly you can
communicate you know fast you can get
back and they've got 1,500 people they
can't get their communication this the
strength of this story is a recognition
of there were the things at that
airplane that you would not pay
attention to that were vastly better
than that then the enemy and the set of
spending all this time thinking about
what we don't do well is build a plan
time around your strengths and then
outmaneuver them meaning maneuver more
quickly maybe you're not doing it maybe
return isn't as fast you're climbing as
fast and watch them react they're
reacting to your first move when you're
on move number three when they're
reacting to your second move
you're on move number seven
and all of a sudden in and ten-to-one by
the way just tend to want his staggering
I mean that is easy it's crazy to think
about what for every hundred airplanes
the enemy lost we lost 10 think about
that with an inferior machine that story
is my is my favorite sort of tell
because we're used to having right now
in the American military our stuff is
better our equipment is better that's
why when that is not why we went as a
matter of fact if your plan is it just
leverage the better equipment you're
gonna lose you know what your enemy is
doing right now figuring out what your
weakness is all you know how you're
gonna maneuver how they're gonna
maneuver on it that's right that's
exactly what they're doing another
important part of this okay because of
its bubble canopy the f-86 pilot had
better visibility the better field of
view provided better situational
awareness and contributed to the fast
transition because it allowed the pilot
to understand changing situations more
quickly what the way that translates
when you're not in a cockpit is it
translates into detaching from the
situation taking a look at what's going
on and actually being able to see what's
happening what do you see what do you
actually see and if you see what's
happening then you can react faster you
can make those transitions happen
quicker
that's this massive advantage that you
can have and the amount of people that I
know that do a good job of detaching and
taking a step back is a very small
number it's a very small number and
everyone that I know that can do it and
do it well they dominate yeah
they dominate that dominant when you are
not detached the only thing that is in
focus is the one thing you're looking at
and everything else is blurry
it literally is it you don't see those
other things and those are all the other
things happening around you that you
actually need to be reacting to another
thing so the other thing that you had is
these high powered hydraulic controls
okay which allowed you to transition
quicker you know what stops people from
transitioning mentally from one thing to
something else
it's
what it is is it's there you go it's
their ego thinking hey I actually know
what's happening and I'm not looking and
I'm not seeing anything else because I
what I think is happening is what's
happening I have so much confidence in
myself and I think I'm right so this is
what hey I think the enemy is coming in
from over there
okay cool and I'm not thinking that I
could be wrong
I'm not assessing what anyone else's
input is I'm not listening to what my
subordinates are telling me what my
peers are telling me what my boss is
telling me I think I'm right so I'm not
gonna change anything that I'm doing
right now so those are the two kind of
advantages that we can have in in the
f-86 in our you know you might not be as
smart as your other someone else you
might not you might not have the
cognitive capacity you might not have
that charisma that someone else's has
but if you can detach and you can
actually be humble enough to assess
honestly what's going on void of your
own ego clouding your vision you can do
these two things you can Minh you can
see better and you can maneuver more
quickly that idea of seeing better and
I've spent a lot of my time thinking
about what this means in the private
sector now is even how you measure
success you talked about being paranoid
just a minute ago about what a good
leader and a good organization what
they're paranoid about the way we
measure success is revenue there's a
whole bunch of ways we have this
objective measurement we're making more
money than we did what we're growing
what a really good leader is actually
doing is what's happening where are we
gonna be in three years my vision isn't
just the next quarter my vision is is
the things that I'm doing and you have
to actually pay attention on what your
competition now you don't spend all your
percent of your time in your competition
but you're paying attention to and your
vision is actually the farthest
downrange as it can possibly be because
if we think quarter to quarter and
sometimes we even sometimes think year
to year and these big companies we work
with this long game this long plan is
recognizing what we're doing now this
isn't gonna work
forever we are going to have to change
we have to see where we were where we
were going and that is going to change
all the time and that requires as a
leader to be
looking up and out all the time you ask
that question of the muster when should
we be thinking strategically people like
well maybe you're actually I got asked
that day and the answer is all the time
all the time and it's that vision of
looking of if you don't have an idea of
where you're gonna be down the road
you're never gonna get to where you need
to be and it's the same story of hey the
the win was we took this hill okay
what did taking this hill allow us to do
and if you didn't have a vision of where
we needed to go and why that hill is
important you should have just bypassed
the hill arms together because that's
not getting you where you need to be and
a leader a good leader has to be able to
do that and that's that vision isn't
isn't always just literal vision it's
actually where is this organization
gonna go because when you're inside and
you're a tactical guy like most your
employees are doing tactical things they
don't see that they don't see the vision
and where and if you can't impart that
on them and let them understand what the
vision is they're gonna drive you in the
wrong direction not not because they're
careless and not because they don't
because they simply don't see it and for
a leader to be able to see it and
articulate that's really very few
leaders are able to do that really well
and guide their organizations in that
direction
yes that's a tough combo to come up with
the person that can has the vision and
then that can can impart that division
that vision but and that means
implicitly that you have to translate
that vision to various types of people
that are inside your organization and it
is definitely challenge and of course
the dichotomy to all of this is if you
know strategically in jujitsu we want to
get the top position and we want to
dominate that position then we want to
submit the person if we don't defend the
shape the choke we're getting choked if
you don't make it through this quarter
you're right you that's good you you had
a good strategic vision and you can you
lose tactically and lose strategically
and doing so yes you absolutely can you
absolutely can you can not pay attention
to what's going on right in front of you
and you can you can end up getting
destroyed yes there was the ten to one
we
it wasn't a ten to zero no she that's
right back to the book American pilot
developed new tactics based on these two
advantages when they engage the MiG's
they sought to put them through a series
of maneuvers the f-86 faster transitions
between maneuvers gave a time advantage
the pilot transformed into a position
advantage often when the MIG pilots
realized what was happening they
panicked and thereby made the Americans
job even easier these tactics illustrate
the fast the way fast transitions
contribute to overall speed into a time
advantage the importance of the time and
speed in a broader sense has been
brought out in the work of john-boy to
follow former colonel in the US Air
Force
Boyd studied a wide variety of historic
battles campaigns at Wars he noted that
where numerically inferior forces had
defeated their opponents they often did
so by presenting the other side with a
sudden unexpected change or series of
changes the superior forces fell victim
because they could not adjust to the
changes in a timely manner
generally defeat came at a relatively
small cost to the victor this research
led to the Boyd theory which states that
conflict may be viewed as a time as time
competitive cycles of observation
orientation decision action the loop
first each party to a conflict enters
the fray by observing himself as
surroundings and as enemy and tactics
this equates the adopt a ssin the
adoption of a hunting insect
instinct searching actively looking
hunting for the enemy and seeing what is
he what he is doing or about to do it
also includes anticipating the enemy's
next move getting inside of his mind
second based upon these observations the
combatant Orient's to the situation that
is produces a mental image of the
situation and gains situational
awareness this awareness becomes the
foundation of which to erect a plan
generally better the orientation the
better the plan next based on this
orientation the combatant decides upon a
course of action the decision is
developed into a plan that can be
disseminated among subordinates for
their planning and execution last the
combatant acts or puts the decision into
effect in tactics
is the execution phase where the
decision or plan is implemented since
this action has changed the situation
the combatant again observes beginning
the cycle anew this is called the you
loop yet some there it is there to get
some and you know this thing came out of
airplane against airplane it's that MIG
f-86 story the Marine Corps saw this and
the entire maneuver warfare concept for
the Marine Corps came from this guy
which is incredible to think about but
it's that same we're a numerically
inferior force with relatively limited
loss can outperform it overwhelm a
massively inferior enemy massively a
superior sized enemy which is which
isn't amazing just based on speed of
maneuver the Boyd theory helps to define
the word maneuver it means being
consistently faster than our opponent as
our enemy observes and Orient's on our
initial action we must be observing
orienting deciding and acting upon our
second action as we enact our third
fourth and fifth mood by the time by the
time gap between our actions and our
enemy actions increases and increasingly
widens the our enemy falls behind in a
panicked game of catch-up he tries to
respond to our penetration we attack his
reserves and his command and control he
counter-attacks with his mobile reserve
we bypass with helicopter-borne forces
everything he does is too late I think
that sounds like a lot like rolling
would you do with someone that's better
than you that's exactly what it feels
like it's the same thing man thus the
military answer to this question what is
speed is not simple nonetheless it is
central to every aspect of tactics as
General George Patton said in small
operations as in large speed is the
essential element of success we should
also exercise caution so as to not
confuse here comes the dichotomy we
should also exercise caution so as to
not confuse speed with haste General
Patton made this observation haste and
speed there is a great difference
between these two words haste exists
when troops are committed without proper
reconnaissance without the arrangement
for proper supporting fire and before
every available man has been brought up
the result of such an attack will be to
get the troops into early action but to
complete the action very slowly speed is
acquired by making the necessary
reconnaissance providing the proper
artillery support bringing up every
available man and then launching the
attack with a predetermined plan so that
the time under fire will be reduced to a
minimum so there's a dichotomy always
there's a dichotomy one with everything
have to write a book about that check
becoming faster now we see clearly the
importance of speed we want to be fast
how do we do it we start by recognizing
the importance of time as leaders of
Marines we have responsibility to make
things happen fast our sense of the
importance of time of urgency must
direct our actions we must work to
create and build that sense within
ourselves this is the kind of thing you
read to yourself before you go to bed at
night and when you wake up in the
morning we have a responsibility to make
things happen fast once we have it there
are a number of things we can do to
increase speed first we can keep
everything simple simplicity promotes
speed complexity slows things down
simplicity should be central to our
plans our staffs large staffs maybe one
of awards greatest consumers of the time
our command and control and our own
actions so this is why if you saw my
tasking it going to assault some they
were in the same formation they were
always in or damn close to it second
speed is increased through
decentralization decentralization is an
important concept in the execution
maneuver warfare how do we achieve
decentralization while still maintaining
control we use two main tools to provide
that required to provide their required
control of the effort and the
decentralization of its execution these
tools our mission tactics and
commander's intent mission tactics is
the assignment of a mission to a
subordinate without specifying how the
mission must be accomplished is a key
tenet of maneuver warfare in mission
tactics the higher commander describes
the mission and explains its purpose the
subordinate commander determines the
tactics needed to accomplish the task
based on the way the mission but based
on the mission and the higher
commander's intent in this way each
leader can act quickly as the situation
changes without passing information up
the chain of command and waiting for
orders to come back down speed is
greatly increased by this
decentralization process according to
John a English and his work on infantry
decentralization has been one of the
most significant features of modern war
English wrote in the confused and often
chaotic battlefield environment of today
only the smallest groups are likely to
keep together particularly during
critical moments in such circumstances
individuals rally around their leader
who armed with the knowledge of the
purpose or intent behind their task can
lead them toward success and this is
what we talk about
all the time decentralized command the
fourth law of combat and I often
describe it even though it's last it's
certainly not least you need to have the
others in place to effectively execute
decentralized command there has to be a
simple plan you have to have a team
that's going to cover and move for each
other you have to know what the
priorities are but then you have to have
decentralized command and the way you
get decentralized command is not by
explicitly giving em your lism there's a
there's a book and the Germans as we
were as we were implementing
decentralized command and maneuver
warfare in America
we started doing was we started anding
adding the commander's intent to like
the last slide of a brief and so
commander's intent and I'm going back to
the book and then we'll wrap back to
that the commander's intent provides an
overall purpose for accomplishing the
tasks assigned through mission tactics
although the situation may change
subordinates who clearly understand the
purpose that means why and act to
accomplish that purpose can adapt to a
changing circumstance on their own
without risking diffusion or effort of
of effort or loss of tempo subordinate
commanders will be able to carry on this
mission on their own initiative and
through lateral coordination with other
subunits rather than running every
decision through the higher command for
approval so in this this German was
looking at the way that we're planning
and the Germans you know they're the
ones that kind of pushed forward with
this idea of mission mission tactics and
commanders intend really decentralized
command but he he would see the
commander's intent at the end of a brief
there be a hundred slides hundred
PowerPoint slides in a brief and then
the last slide would say hey the
commander's a tenth of this operation is
to blah blah blah then this German said
that last slide can actually replace
this entire brief what is it that you
want me to do you just spent a hundred
you spent an hour telling me all the
different ways you want me to do
something all I need to know is what is
it you want me to do why do you want me
to do it and I'll go make it happen when
when we're working the the idea of the
centralized command comes up all the
time as you might guess and I know you
know that cuz you've seen it over and
over again and initially when we're
talking about some of the frustration of
junior leaders in the organization
mid-level managers may be supervisors
they get really frustrated that their
senior leadership doesn't understand
what's going on and they can't they
don't they don't have what they need to
solve the problems and I say hey who
here wants their leaders solving their
problems for them and they'll put their
hand up an issue they're like and they
that's their initial reaction cuz you
can do they're frustrated and they know
my goal is let's let's think about that
for a second do you want your
is coming down here to your world and
actually applying solutions to your
problems and they stop to think and they
look no no I don't I don't want that
like well why don't you want them doing
that and then Everly what they come down
to is that because they don't understand
what I'm dealing with day to day I'm
like that's that's exactly right because
if they did come down to your world
they don't have every single minute of
every single day of all the context you
have of the problem you're dealing with
and no matter what they do it's gonna be
wrong cuz they don't understand it as
well as you do and what and on both
sides what people are thriving for
anything is just tell me what you want
me to accomplish and then leave me alone
because I can actually do that better
and then if you reverse that with the
senior leaders like the same thing is
they don't want to be down there because
it takes them away from all these other
things and really all is required is for
the leader to have the vision and this
abhorrent leader to understand what are
we trying to get done yeah you know it's
a good converse to that question when
you ask the subordinates hey do you want
your subordinate do you want your boss
to to to fix your problems for you and
of course they all say yes another way
you could broach that question with an
equally probably predictable answer is
if you say to the leaders hey do you
want your folks just to do what you tell
them to do and of course they're all
gonna say oh yes absolutely and then it
doesn't take very long into that
conversation before you realize that
they have no idea how to actually
accomplish what it is that they envision
they have no idea how to operate that
piece of equipment
they have no idea how to program that
piece of software they have no idea of
any of those things and so is same
answer it's like yeah that seems like
good ends like what I want but that's
not what you want what you want is
subordinates you want decentralized
command where everybody leads everyone
solves problems everyone's moving
towards the unified vision that has been
clearly stated by the boss of what the
commander's intent is that's what you
want that's how you run an organization
you would think that that would be what
everyone would be striving for and you
would think that in striving for it it
would come to be clear how you actually
do it and how you actually give people
decentralized command is by actually
letting go letting go let people let
Lafe babban go and run the operation let
Seth stone go and make it happen and yes
do I train them to get ready for that
absolutely do I build a relationships
right Justin yes do they understand
where I stand what the parameters are
when do they know how much they're
allowed to maneuver do they know what
line they should never cross yes they do
you know and that allows me to say yeah
go get some you go you know what you
need to get got done go make it happen
and by the way it's not just life and
Seth there's other element it's and
RuPaul and RuPaul go run operations the
other assistant platoon commanders Mike
Cirelli go run go make it happen can't
run how am I gonna run five operations
at the same time I can so that's what
you do that's decentralized command to
the book a third way to become faster as
through experience experience breeds
speed experience give units gives units
advantages over less experienced units
this is why veteran units are usually
much faster than green untried units if
we are familiar with a situation or at
least know generally what to expect we
can think act and move faster little
overlay in peacetime our Marines are not
likely to be combat veterans still we
can give them experience through
tactical decision games and sand table
exercises wargames field exercises and
rehearsals these and other forms of
training help reduce the stress and
confusion of combat another way in which
experience helps us become faster is
through the use of implicit
communications implicit communications
are mutual understandings that
require little or no actual talking or
writing for example two
company commanders know each other well
they think alike because their battalion
commanders established standard
operating procedures and has schooled
subordinate commanders in approach to
war this is exactly what I was talking
about Saif and Lafe those guys know
there's implicit communication I need to
ask me they know thus the company
commander of Company B Company Bravo
does not need to talk with a company
commander of company charlie very often
in action because each knows from common
past experiences and from daily
observations how the other is likely to
react in many different situations if
Bravo company's commander creates an
opportunity Charlie company's commander
will take advantage of it that is
implicit communication it is faster and
more reliable it is more reliable than
in an explicit communication trying to
pass words or messages back and forth
over telephone radius there are so many
things that I had that my guys knew the
implicit it was implied they understood
exactly what I was coming from from the
way that they behaved on the battlefield
the way they behaved in the on Liberty
everything it was like okay well there's
a lot like what I just said there's a
line that they know they they knew what
that line was yeah they knew what that
line was what also goes to show and and
prove why you can't do D central you
can't do this thing this fourth law of
combat if you don't have the beginning
if you it's that implied communication
that's the strength of your relationship
with these people it's how well they
know you how much they trust you is how
much you understand them in and it's how
strong that first rule is is what allows
you to do this thing that actually if
you kind of think about in some more
some terms the centralized command you
could actually make an argument that
it's the most important thing in combat
in this particular case because it's so
required because you as a leader can't
be in 15 different places but no matter
what you do if you don't have the
beginning if you don't have the
foundation if you don't have a good
relationship you can never do this you
can never have implied communication
because I'll never really understand
what it means if I haven't and and you
and you can't skip this you can't
accelerate this again I'm decentralized
command eyes like well that's great but
if you don't have a good number
relationship with your people it won't
work
we were at one of the musters we were
done I think was the San Francisco
muster
maybe but anyways we were having our
debrief and it was people had to go so
it was a smaller debrief not everyone
was there Jamie who is our Director of
Operations who is the logistician behind
the muster who handles everything that's
happening and it's completely
decentralized but we get done with the
muster and of course everything was just
impeccably run from you know if someone
has to wait in line for 15 seconds to
register what we get I think that's a
failure right so is so when we got done
we're in this room and I like I could
see and you know people were coming up
to me saying this I've never been an
event that was run this smoothly there
don't even talking about what they
learned they're just saying how is this
thing run so smoothly and how is
everything so professional and how is
every little thing that that occurs
perfect you know so ed more so we get in
this debrief room and and you know and
what I said was I said to Jamie and Jen
who didn't Linda kind of the powerhouse
of the trio who run all these logistics
I said you know I should have said this
before any of these musters but
everything that happens at the muster is
a complete reflection of our company of
Echelon front if we can't run a smooth
check-in then who are we to be advising
people you know as to how to run an
organization and the fact of the matter
is so so I never said that to them and
yet they the the team
the Echelon front team the volunteers
well everyone that shows up they go to
the enth degree to make sure that
everything is smooth to make sure that
ever and that that this is clear Jamie
never had to ever hear those words come
from my mouth because Jamie knows me and
Jamie knows that what how I roll is like
oh this will be the best thing that
everyone anyone ever goes to that is the
standard now I never said that to her
she knew 100% in her soul that's how we
roll if there was a question between hey
you know what we can we can say we can
make this a little easier on the
volunteers are we or on me on the
employees or we can we can adjust this a
little bit and and save a little bit of
money here or hey it doesn't matter if
the if the people that are attending
might not be able to see the whole like
whatever whatever the case may be
whatever it was the the thing that she
knows that the team knows that the rest
of her twitch she implied that right
down to her whole team because you know
she's got 20 people there that are
working for and they're all have the
same mindset which is we will do
everything to the entropy okay well will
we make mistakes absolutely well will we
drop the ball sometimes yes we will but
when we drop that ball we will pick it
up we will recover it and we will run
that thing for a touchdown and make it
up to the person that you or whoever was
affected so that's like a classic
example of implied communication I don't
need to tell you hey we're gonna show up
early for the for the people that were
working with tomorrow lookey you don't
need to hear that right like this is
just a known thing that's the way it is
like you said earlier you're not showing
up saying you know what I only have time
to prepare so I'm just kind of kind of
wing it today okay that's not happening
that's not what we're doing
and so those kind of implanting and Lafe
has great examples where he was making
decisions and making calls and something
I never said to but you come back and
said hey this was happening this is what
I did but I'd be like yeah and he'd say
yeah I didn't mean to call you and say
hey what do you think we should do here
you know and this is because the trust
the relationship then you're right
does take time to build and what's
really scary is when people when the
trust isn't there when the relationship
isn't there and people start trying to
guess what the implied communication was
I thought you would have wanted me to do
that
and that's something that I did so so I
would have guys that would come let's
say roll through when I was up to in
command was at asking the commander
someone might roll through and go out on
an operation here or there and they
didn't they thought they knew me or they
thought they knew life and all of a
sudden they'd make a move out there on
the battlefield Nikko oh man that was
not a good move and clearly I did a
failure too to let them know that that
this was not what we're doing and
because my because my guys knew me and
they knew what the implied communication
was they didn't they did it and I didn't
have to make it I didn't have to be
verbal with it but someone that just
shows up for a you know a week and all
of a sudden they're out or an operation
they do something that's dumb
my fault our fault as leaders because we
didn't make it explicitly clear hey
here's what's going on here's how we
here's why we don't do that here's why
we don't a fire warning shots from from
a sniper overwatch this seems like a
this seems like a obvious thing yeah you
know and Lafe sitting in a platoon brief
wouldn't say hey guys we're not taking
warning shots it's implied that it's a
clandestine situation as long as we can
keep it that way and if we when we have
to when we have to go we're gonna start
killing people not finding warning shots
you're not you're warning people that
don't know we're there this doesn't make
sense
but you know what happens and that
particular thing happened and again we
as leaders needed to understand hey we
don't have that full relationship we
don't people don't understand things as
well so you have to watch out when
people start trying to guess what the
implied communication is I don't want
you to guess so I don't want you to
guess at what I'm thinking I want you if
you don't if you're not sure I want you
to actually raise your hand and say hey
Jocko my guess is that you're doing this
but I don't want to guess I want to
actually know so if you're thinking
something that's my responsibility as a
leader to say hey
you don't if you're not sure hit me up
hit me up yeah back to the book another
way speed gains from experience is the
development of lateral communications or
coordination if all communication is up
and down the chain of command action
will move slowly
if commanders and leaders in every level
level communicate laterally if we as
leaders talk directly to other leaders
action moves much faster lateral
communication is not a natural
consequence of mission orders it must be
practiced in training it results from
the confidence of the higher commander
who has through past experiences found
that subordinates can exercise
initiative based on the assigned mission
and commanders stated intent as you just
said yeah a good example of lateral
communications comes from aviation Dave
Burke in the air the pilots of a flight
of aircraft communicate laterally as a
matter of course a pilot who who needs
to talk to another does so a message
need not go through the mission
commander and then be related to the
other pilot events would quickly outpace
communication if pilots tried to talk
that way the commute the same procedures
may be employed by ground combat and
logistics as units as well what when
what parameters are you given where it's
like ok you do need to run it through
the chain of command is that like hey
I'm going out of the a oh man yeah like
I'm Dom leaving I got a depart the area
something like that it's such a small
list it would really it would really
boil down to a deviation of what our
main practices our overarching SOPs that
hey these are just some big foundational
things that we do it would have to be
something like I'm leaving a location
that everybody's probably thinks I
shouldn't because I think something else
is happening and if I don't have the big
picture maybe ok hey look this is what's
happening this is a critical decision
maybe
but the reality is is the question
you're asking me I'm thinking I don't
even know if I have a good example where
I would have to defer to the chain of
command given how limited my time and
how you know you're on minutes you have
and so if I spend ten minutes trying to
work this answer out that's probably all
the time actually it really had to go
execute anyway so the answer the
question is I could barely think of an
example that I would have to stop what
we're doing ask the boss who's somewhere
else can I go do this yeah and on the
ground it's really it's real easy hey
we're gonna go across this line to this
limit of advance do we have can we do
can we do that is there something else
going on that would create risk if I can
you tell someone else that I'm moving
into their AO I want to hit a building
that wasn't on the target list can I do
it you know so and you know what's
interesting is again life and Seth they
they like they just knew what I don't
think ever
Lafe did something where I came back and
said you should have asked or say that
hey you should have told me what was
going on you should have asked me what
was going on those guys knew again
implicit communications hey I'm leaving
I'm I'm going across this limit of
advance I'm calling jockle and just let
him know or hey I'm gonna hit this
building I'm gonna go or hey I'm I'm
doing this difference for the first time
on an operation yeah I'm gonna check
with Jacqueline see like that's never
did I say to myself you should have told
me and there was and there was not a lot
of times where they were telling me
something where I was like dude come on
of course go do it right the both of
those guys has such a good feel for and
they might air towards letting me know
of course which i think is the good way
to air you know hey occasionally maybe
I'd be like yeah man no problem of
course but I would never say dude just
do it what's wrong with you no I'd
rather you lean towards letting me know
what's going on and I think that's a
that's a huge distinction the difference
between asking for permission and
informing your leadership those are very
different things so in that same
question I would let them know whoever
they all the time hey I'm moving here
I'm doing this I'm and it is an
informative I'm gonna let my leadership
know almost as much as I can but in
terms of like I don't
know if I should do this I'm gonna die
think I should stopping with the flow
this tempo to get permission because my
leadership had created this level of
friction that I couldn't make real-time
decisions the deference to the chain of
command that up and down that he talked
about we even went so far that if you
were my squadron commander and I was a
captain in Europe colonel and on this
particular mission I was the flight lead
and you were number two you were my
wingman
your rank did not go with you into the
cockpit it didn't matter that you were
the squadron commander I wouldn't treat
you like a squadron commander in the
airplane I treat you like a wingman and
the expectation was that you would treat
me like a flight lead and whatever the
natural a ship is there and that's a
good one because we often get asked well
you know you your chain of command is so
higher hierarchy in the military and the
example that I always bring up is a
preacher a breach team so you have a
breach team leader that's running the
breach and when that breach team leader
looks at me even though all nine ranks
above him in the military or whatever
four ranks above him five rank actually
more than that a lot of ranks above yeah
if he looks at me and says backup you
normally do I backup he tells me to get
down you know to get down
that's the way it works yeah so he's got
the tactical control over that situation
and he's the guy in charge and also I'd
say this when you when you talk about
asking me like ask people like how often
did life or Seth or one of the other
junior officers say hey what should I do
they almost never did that because I
beat that one out of my battle that one
I don't we're not doing this without
doing this you come up with a solution
you tell me what you're gonna do so it
was almost always they were telling me
for giving me the opportunity to negate
if you know if they said hey I want to
go to move across the summit of advance
gives me the opportunity to say do it or
negative there's already friendly forces
in that building hold what you got or
whatever yeah so yeah there wasn't there
was not a lot of asking me what to do as
and and that was there early on sure the
further along we got the less and less
those guys asked me anything and I was
just gonna conclude it that same thing
as this is that how I was as a squadron
commander in day one no no on day one I
wasn't like that
and it that took a little bit time to
get to that evolution that idea of
decentralized command is built on those
relationships on day one you got to
figure out those
things and it does take a little bit of
time so if you've got a brand new team
and you just got brought into an
organization and run your team that
doesn't mean you just cut them loose on
day one it doesn't mean that you
actually need to spend some time with a
little more closer control than you
might like the sooner you get to that
the better but yeah absolutely you got
to build those relationships out of the
gate so you can get to that point and if
you kind of lose too soon it's every bit
as bad as micromanaging them when they
don't need to be micromanaged back to
the book a fourth way to become faster
is by the commander's positioning
himself at the point of friction this
position may be with the main effort a
supporting effort or in the rear a
commander who is forward can instantly
influence the battle as a situation
develops for the same reason a commander
may choose a position at a crucial
crossroad during a night movement or
where the unit is pushing supplies
forward or wear a counter attack force
is in the defense may be cited the key
is to be where we can best influence the
actions of our units as Marines we
believe in leading from the front since
that is where most friction points occur
but they may occur elsewhere we must
choose our positions accordingly through
our world war ii and his career
Lieutenant General Louis B chesty puller
believed that Marines had to lead from
where the fighting was this command
quote post business this command post
business will ruin the American army and
Marines if it hasn't watched he said
while he was the commanding officer of
1st battalion 7th Marines at Guadalcanal
has a battalion commander puller usually
positioned himself directly behind the
point element of his battalion and his
headquarters element directly behind the
lead company so that he could best
influence the actions of his unit from
this location he was able to impose his
will and personally affect the outcome
of the engagement depending on the
situation he could also be found at
other points on the march or in his
perimeter his idea was to be where he
could best influence the action notice
even though it's leading from the front
he put himself behind the point element
of his battalion that's been not at in
the point Helmand because then he's the
guy shooting his freakin right right not
making decisions
it's the same thing in aviation and so
there's a little bit of inherent in
flexibility in maybe ich because you
can't take your aircraft and go 75 mile
you can't just leave yourself as the
mission commander so actually when you
have a mission of 24 airplanes
you've got guys that are dedicated as
fighters to shoot down enemy aircraft
and you know what that's the sexy
mission everybody wants a MIG kill I
want to shoot my missile and shoot down
an airplane because that sounds cool and
that sounds like the most fun and that's
what people want the real reason we're
out there the mission we're almost
always doing is to doose's to blow
something up on the ground to affect
some air-to-ground influence to kill
some target on the ground so you know
where the mission commander is the guy
in charge of the whole thing on every
mission he's with the strike element
he's with the element that's actually a
full wave behind the leading element
which is the firing element which clears
everything out and he's actually in the
striker element cuz he a can see
everything is out in front of him he's
actually with the element that will have
the most of an amount of impact to the
mission or at least that's the point
dropping bombs - oh he is I mean every
airplane event I mean from resources and
they're up there yeah we're up there
were dropping bombs and he's gonna be at
some point he's gonna roll in and go
he'll get tactical for a few minutes he
will he'll go right through the soda
straw in the pump yeah that's exactly
right in the pop but the just like the
amount of time that he's gonna be doing
that is 90 seconds on an hour and a half
mission and he will actually put himself
behind that initial wave and be with
what is most likely the point of
friction at the bottom line is this
tactical principle that could apply to a
Marine Lance Corporal a platoon
commander a battalion it's the same
thing in aviation it's the same
responsibility and the mission commander
oh by the way doesn't have to be the
senior ranking guy it doesn't have to be
who was this squad it's not always the
squadron commander he's not it's it's
you guys are going here we're going here
and this is and once I cut you loose and
go to your thing and I was you know
first when we did Oh F you know and
we're in Afghanistan this operation
anaconda was his big mission I was on
night zero of anaconda as a captain I
was leading a formation and the guy I
was leading was my operations officer he
outranked me by two ranks he was way
more experienced than me but on that
mission the squadron commander gave me
the lead
and he flew off my wing is it a work
load is it a work load issue why why did
they do it that way um it's in other
words if I plan every single mission
eventually I just can't don't have the
capacity to plan them all so instead you
planned the next one and that way I can
get some rest or I can you know be ready
yeah so he can actually go be an
Operations Officer because what he was
doing for most of that day rather than
planning that mission he was forecasting
the next 96 hours of sustained combat
operations
I can't they also can't afford an we
he's gotta fly we don't have a certain
number of pilots or number airplanes but
the rank it wasn't a matter is who's
gonna be able to get that job done in
the OP so in the squadron commander
we're doing long-range strategic stuff
I've spent the entire day planning and
he jumped on my wing and never wants it
he take try to take control of that
situation for me you know from beginning
to end
gotta stay humble back to the book
finally it is important not only to be
faster but to maintain that speed
through time this endurance is made
possible through physical and mental
fitness physical fitness develops not
only speed energy and agility to move
faster but it also develops the
endurance to maintain that speed for
longer durations with endurance we not
only outpace the enemy but maintain a
higher tempo longer than he can mental
fitness builds the ability to
concentrate for longer periods of time
and to penetrate below the surface of a
problem for this reason fitness plays an
important part in the life of every
Marine Patton once said high physical
condition is vital to victory and here's
the conclusion of this chapter we must
be faster than our opponent this means
we must move fast but more importantly
we must act faster than our enemy the
aim is to tailor our tactics so that we
can act faster than the enemy force can
react our ability to plan decide and
execute faster than our enemy creates
and
advantage that we can exploit we have
just discussed ways to improve our speed
readers of this publication may think of
additional ways to be fast when you find
one that works tell your fellow Marines
about it so they can use it to anything
that works to make you faster is good
even if it is not yet in the books
well speed wise we're not doing real
good on this podcast right now because
we are now something like three hours
deep and we only made it through another
two chapters so probably not exactly the
fastest thing but we are going deep and
we're getting into it the fact that you
know we were just talking about the fact
that we need to keep our mental and
physical fitness up in the game there's
ways that we can there's ways that we
can do that one of the ways that we can
do that is a little thing that we like
to call jiu-jitsu how many times that we
talk about you just do today I don't
think it's an overwhelming number of
times but it's definitely there ask me
how many times I thought about it so
jiu-jitsu Brazilian jiu-jitsu if you're
not training in it there's some real
good reason not to train in it I get
asked a lot of height well you know I'm
52 years old should I start do Jitsu yes
yes I'm a hundred and thirty pound
female that's forty eight years old
should I start do Jitsu yes
I'm my son is only nine years old should
he start you Jitsu yes well it's my
daughter and she gets uncomfortable
around people should she do jiu-jitsu
yes you get where I'm going here yes so
you gonna change some jiu-jitsu if
you're gonna train some jiu-jitsu you're
gonna want to get Aggie cuz you're gonna
run Doogie and noogie jiu-jitsu origin
main calm
this is our jiu-jitsu company and we're
not just making geese we're also making
rash guards we're making t-shirts wear
me
do you wear joggers we have no one here
to talk about joggers things that goes
on vacation
apparently echo likes the joggers I
tried him on one time it was hilarious
they are not for me but you know what
are for me jeans
origin jeans made in America they have a
little bit of stretch a little bit of
flexibility when you see them you have
to kind of break actually watch the
watch the video that Pete made that
credit he turns the jeans inside out and
shows you what quality looks like that's
something that's that's important to see
otherwise you don't understand it and
then we got supplements too at origin
main comm join warfare krill oil
discipline and discipline go of which
Dave partook again like clockwork we're
about to I'm about to say good evening
and he's taking a discipline go yep
getting it in the gullet yeah you're
talking about supplements too just real
quick in the joint warfare the best way
to know if joint warfare is working stop
taking it for a couple days go on the
road and don't bring it with you more
that's it and then I don't like them
yeah that you won't make it more than
once but if you want to know if it's
working stop taking it for a couple days
that stuff is working we talked about
this one last time but the joint warfare
knee elbow whatever it is that stuff is
working if you get off that you're gonna
feel it right away you know that's we
have you can get subscriptions to our to
our gear at origin mancom and that's a
one that's what I think that's the
highest subscription rate the auto
refill the auto we felt fresh you're
gonna get this and what you wonder from
why why do people want to auto refill
that that's why yeah because people they
forget to reorder it and all of a sudden
they're off the off the joint warfare
for a few days they feel like crap and
so they go never making that mistake
again you should see the stockpile of a
joint water fair I have
it's ridiculous I will never run out of
joint warfare good so join warfare krill
oil
come on is another like a universal just
universal goodness and and I haven't not
taken krill oil and enjoying warfare in
so long I came to tell you like what it
feels like to not take them or not I'm
not going there and milk which
apparently according to our last podcast
you're just you're on the strawberry
milk train so the thing with strawberry
is it's the one it's so of all it and
look I have a good supply of all of them
the what strawberry did to me is the
first one I'm taking whatever there is
there's no reason to have it like every
other time was hey I want to replace a
meal or any other extra protein or I'm
on the go
I'll take strawberry for no reason it's
that good that's the one little
difference between strawberry and the
rest is out like no reason for this
other than I just love it so I can blame
I guess I can blame strawberry but
that's what I'm my relations with
strawberries I'll take it when I don't
need to cuz it's just so good the thing
that I love about all the flavors of all
is when I get done eating even if I'm
like happy I had a good meal I had a big
giant let's face it I'm having a big rib
eye maybe it's a bone-in rib eye maybe
it's a tomahawk rib eye which I will not
hesitate to order at all even then I'll
get home I mean I'll eat up either you
know what 22 ounce tomahawk rib eye
bless that thing beautiful I'll destroy
that thing I'll get home and I'll be
like you know what I need just a little
hitter you need to get that monkey here
to to I mean why would you you know they
have dessert on the menu right you have
they have does there's a reason that
they have dessert on the menu in a
steakhouse right it's because people
even though they got to eat the steak
even though they had they put down the
tomahawk rib eye even though they did
that they still want something like that
little dichotomy they want a little
little
a little pallet dichotomy is what's
going on and it did the the moment
header the Yvonne style the mo cater can
definitely get you that dichotomy of
flavor that you need it can and I know
we're not being discipline of the time
but here's the thing with the milk to is
it used to be that if you wanted to get
that little sweetness the thing there
wasn't any real substitute for what was
on the dessert menu everything was gonna
be kind of not quite right in the little
chocolaty but and so you had to get the
dessert and actually with the milk you
don't go you know it was good but it
wasn't quite it's now just as good oh so
you don't you don't need that dessert
menu anymore because it used to be the
only way to get that hitter was the more
like it
it's that good and there's warrior kid
milk too cuz cuz most of us are not
trying to literally give our children
poison in the form of sugar
so get your skids those strawberry or
chocolate warrior kid monk haters so
they get stronger and faster and become
better human beings and don't forget
about that white tea because there's not
too many people out there that just
don't want an 8,000 pound deadlift
which is guaranteed 100% double I'm
trying to think of echo you normally
covers this Park sees more you've got
the science down triple Platt placebo
triple blind study has been done and
then we have a store it's called choco
store where you can get you can get
t-shirts rash guards truckers hats
beanies you can get flex fits hats I
don't think it were you wear a baseball
hat ever yeah I have the I got the
trucker hat oh okay so here's the thing
with the Jocko store is so I actually
have access to the Jocko store directly
I don't I don't have to go to Jocko
store doc I'm one of the lucky ones it
has
to this but here's the thing I don't get
stuff from the Jocko store because it's
accessible to me I get it because those
are the best teachers that I got I'm
serious like I get that stuff ii went
and when echo has a hater there's a rash
guard
I don't wear just because he gave it to
me because I actually could if I even
and I go buy a rash guard I would I'd
spend the money to get the rash guard
that I wanted I actually uses this get
wear this stuff because it's the stuff
that I like the most and it isn't just
because I can call echo be like hey bro
hook me up which I can and that you know
what that's good to go does he hook you
up he hooks me echo just went on report
okay and not only is he looking up Khoa
has his cousin KOA he hooks me up it's
good stuff
and if you don't know this if you
support origin or you support the store
that's actually what supports this
podcast if you--if you ever listened
this podcast and you say to yourself
that was pretty good I got something out
of that then this we appreciate because
that's that's how we make this podcast
is through your support to this podcast
which if you want to subscribe to it you
can do so because well if you listen to
it you subscribe to it and echo thinks
that people don't subscribe to it is he
paranoid should I be more paranoid
should I be freaking out people aren't
subscribe a hang know they're subscribed
if you haven't subscribed subscribe and
also check out the warrior kid podcast
how often do you listen to warrior kid
podcast with your children Dave Burke go
only when they're with me in the car
which is every time I'm with them I'm
driving them somewhere right yeah and
are they you you feel like the lessons
are are sinking it they are two things
one I learned from the podcast that my
kids will learn things at the ages they
are when I didn't think they could I had
they're too young that they're not gonna
get it they do because they reference it
they'll they will tell me things that
they heard they'll let Jocko said this
and and nicely their name is they
actually say uncle Jake's for sure they
say that and then the other piece and if
you're not if you're a if you're a jock
a podcast listener that doesn't have
kids and you're not listening the word
kid podcast I have learned things on the
warrior kid podcast as a parent a ton of
things so it isn't just for them as much
as it is for them
I am the beneficiary that as well and it
is good for them and it is good for me
too do you like my warrior kid podcast
voice so not it I have been a guest on
the warrior kid podcast and I know how
to change my voice just a little bit to
make it more appropriate for the kids no
doubt I didn't consciously do that
I didn't consciously say you know what I
kind of that's just like I was just like
okay I'm talking to kids yeah hey kids
this is the warrior that's like that
just what came out of me
I didn't say okay need to think about
need to get into warrior kid podcast
character no that's just what I'm
talking about trying to engage a bunch
of kids you've got to give it a little
bit of that little bit of that thing
absolutely a little bit of that a little
bit of that so yeah warrior kid podcast
if you want to check that out and don't
forget to check out Irish Oaks ranch
comm for young Aiden that's making soap
on his farm Aidan's in the game yeah so
you can stay clean YouTube channel the
the YouTube channel is called the Jocko
podcast and there's videos on it of this
podcast if you want to see what Dave
Burke looks like you can see if you want
to see what any of the guests or if you
wanna see what I look like then you can
go to there and if you want to get small
excerpts that echo Charles made that he
thinks are legit you can check out you
can subscribe to the YouTube channel and
they've got psychological warfare
couple tracks so that you can overcome
moments of weakness and we also have
flipside campus.com that's Dakota Meyer
listen to podcast 115 yes listen to
podcast 115 just listen to podcast 115
Dakota Meyer hear his story
hear what he has done what he's been
through his life and I talked to Dakota
on a fairly regular basis and
just check out flipside canvas calm
that's that's all you really need to say
on it
dot-com slashed Jocko if you need some
workout gear have the word fitness there
you need some workout gear so you can
Jack some steel checkout on it comm
slash Jocko and get some gear for
yourself and we got some books Dave do
you think of the books get some books
same thing with the podcast you got the
the warrior kid podcast you have the
warrior kid books
way of the warrior kid and marks mission
I've got the third book now way of the
warrior kid where there's a will and we
are talking a lot about Danny Reinhardt
in my house right now and and how much
mark can't stand Danny Reinhardt that
book that the stories in all three of
those works just like with the podcast
my kids are learning things that I
didn't think they were able to learn at
their age and they are and there are
lessons that are applying to their my
daughter's going into fifth grade it's
applying to her world and the people and
the things that she's doing and as a
parent I am stealing so much from those
books to be able to better parent my
kids because of what I know is working
for them in his book so the warrior kids
series he got to get that series and
Mike and the Dragons - just because it's
sort of geared towards a younger kid
same exact thing the the story in that
my kids get it they understand that it
is so legit and then there's discipline
equals freedom Field Manual which is a
book that I wrote and it's answers a lot
of questions that I got asked a lot
about my own personal kind of operating
system I guess for lack of a better word
what to eat how to rest workouts and I
guess the more impactful part is what
I'm thinking about this one equals
freedom Field Manual how to get after if
the audio is on Amazon it's on it's on
mp3 it's not on it it's not on audible
so you can check that out and then
there's extreme ownership and the
dichotomy a leadership which were
written by me and my
brother lave babban when did you read
extreme ownership for the first time
Dave I was at the first book release
Lafe gave it to me I met him in DC and I
had never didn't even know you guys are
writing a book he said come out and join
us he was in DC for that release on that
probably may 2015 I'm guessing October
okay something like that handed me a
copy that was that one you wouldn't we
were all together at an event no it was
it was just life he was in DC on on his
own was it as a for that I'm trying to
think when you okay okay it was before
you and I actually met again well it was
golly the following month it was
probably a month before that check and
cuz I wasn't going to school in DC and
he was out there and he's I hate jumping
I didn't see him in a while
he had me a copy of the book and it was
all new to me and and for all the other
books on that you got to start with you
have to start with extreme ownership
because that's really the thing that
that makes all of it makes sense is you
have to understand that of what that
mindset really means and you have to
read that everything we're talking about
today was a dichotomy this entire one
tech 3 manual is a dichotomy and that's
why you sort of have to have both of
those together and you need to read
those for the rest of them even for the
field manual to really make sense that
mindset of really what extreme motors it
means it underpins all of it you have to
have you have to have both those books
you got to read them and then we got a
still on front where Dave Burke goes in
with the rest of the team and what we do
is we we talk about things that we
talked about today but more important we
give the actual pragmatic hands-on
instruction and assessment to make sure
that leadership inside of an
organization is actually moving in the
right direction from a strategic
perspective and that everyone is on
board and aligned and got that if you
need if you have a problem in your
organization of any kind it's a
leadership problem and we can help you
with your problems all of them
excellent front comm for details on that
we have EF online which is a it's a tool
it's an interactive leadership training
tool
where you will not just get some
repetition on the information but more
important you'll start to absorb it in a
different way in a more comprehensive
way you'll be put into leadership
scenarios that you have to unfold and
unwind and make decisions in by the way
this is an interactive online leadership
training you have to make decisions and
as for good as is the face-to-face
training is as critical as that
face-to-face training is with us it's
it's simply not an inoculation it is not
a one-time thing and this EF online
resource because it actually it's
dynamic even though it's it's pretty
it's dynamic that's what allows you to
get the additional repetitions that
isn't just the same thing over and over
again it allows you to think about what
it means to be a leader and how to
actually problem-solve in real time and
a recognition that you got to think
about that's up every single day yeah
and the way technology is now I mean
there's so many advantages to it for
instance you're in a classroom with 170
people at your event and you're taking
notes on something that Dave Burke just
said and then all of a sudden you look
up and you missed his next little topic
that's not happening with EF online
you're pressing pause you're rewinding
it you're watching it again you're
submitting a question you know you you
got that going on you're going to the QA
you're watching you're you're trying to
make decisions based on what you just
learned when you don't make the right
decision you're having it explained to
you why that decision wasn't the best
decision for you to make at that time so
yeah it's it's it's a great training
tool it is and when one last thing
there's a lot of people that are on EF
online right now a lot of people and
about once a month
flin JP lay me we actually get on to a
live Q&A session so what what folks will
do is they'll go through this training
and they're like I need a little more
fidelity on a little more detail on this
one on the right that down they'll
submit it and on a live Skype session
and I'm like hey Jacko what's your
question he'll ask me that question
there'll be a hundred people listen to
that and we'll dig deep into that one
question to really drive that home and
that's for the folks that are on EF
online not only does it help the person
ask the question there's a hundred
people listening they're taking notes
too because this is it's it's all the
same stuff so I love one of my favorite
things about EF online is those live
Skype sessions
with the people that are run through
that training yeah and one thing that's
nice
from my perspective is you know doing
the live stuff for me on social media
for instance it got it got so I still do
it I need to do it a little bit more
often
but it gets a little crazy because
there's people that are what they they
might not want to have to talk about
leadership which is which is fine which
is great you know I get that that's
there's a broad audience out there but
if you are on EF online yeah you can ask
me a question about your particular
situation yep and you know many
questions I get when I go online and do
a do a Facebook live or or Instagram
live or a or a Twitter what's it called
periscope live I mean there's literally
there be a thousand questions in in 20
minutes
when I did it with I was with Pete and
and Brian we were in New York and you
got to do do an Instagram live you know
QA I said okay who's got questions and
they break it down how old the question
is so like this question came three
minutes ago this question came four
minutes ago my questions it would say
there would be between five and ten
questions no I think it was between like
three and six questions every second so
we'd say there'd be six questions they'd
be this question came four seconds ago
and so it just wasn't feasible and then
and then I gotta sort through all those
so with EF online you're getting that
narrower you're getting a group of
people what are they interested in
they're interested in learning about
leadership there's it's a closed group
so yeah check out EF online that's a
good point the muster Chicago's done
next up is September 19th and 20th
Denver it's it's gonna sell out they've
all sold out if you want to come
register now go to extreme ownership
comp for those details and then of
course we had EF overwatch which what do
you think about EF overwatch Dave I just
came back from a client last week
where we had I spent a day with their
the executive leadership team and it's
the first time I've been with a client
where one of their executive leaders was
placed from you have overwatch a guy who
long service in the military an amazing
career
looked at transition to continue to make
big impact in a company they get
screened and through our organization
what mics rally is done with over
watches make sure they understand these
principles he went off to this company
and the dude is crushing it he's rushing
it he's making massive impact in that
organization and they're benefiting
hugely the this idea of taking the
lessons that they learn in the military
and then centering around the extreme
ownership concepts that we teach and
putting them into an organization and
how much reach they have its overwatch
is awesome it gives a place for our
veterans ago but it also gives for the
private sector to get those lessons in
there and man to see what that guys
doing is so legit and the the idea that
we've talked about a little last podcast
and we brought up a little bit today but
you're overlaying what you know right
we're not we're not taking and imposing
hey this is how we did in the military
no no no and this we talked about this
with our with our candidates that we
placed it's like hey you don't impose
you tell what you know and what you
understand you overlaid onto what this
company is trying to do the leadership
principles are going to be the same but
we take your knowledge and your
experience and you have so look at these
these guys that were getting to fill
these thoughts they have so much they
have so many overlays to place that
they've seen this before they've done
this yeah maybe it's not a it's not the
exact same thing it wasn't in a
manufacturing plant it was in a it was
in a squadron it was as a troop
commander it was as a battalion
commander it was like in one of these
situations where they're going okay oh
yeah I've dealt with this situation
before here's how we can fix it here's
where I see a lack of decentralized man
here's where I see priorities not being
set so that is EF overwatch comm and if
you are not sick of Dave and I yet
talking which you can see we can talk
especially when it comes to these
subjects but if you want to talk to us a
little bit more about it you can find us
on the interwebs on Twitter Instagram
and on the face Dave is at David our
Burk BER ke and I am at
jakka Willick Dave any closing thoughts
Marine Corps manual 1 tag 3 is about
Marine Corps tactics and what it is is
actually about leadership and it applies
everywhere and this has been a blast
this is awesome and what only four
chapters deep and to all the service
members out there in the Army in the
Navy in the Air Force in the Coast Guard
and yes in the Marine Corps and that
includes reservist and Guard units
everyone that's out there that have worn
the cloth of this nation thank you for
making the podcast possible by upholding
freedom and democracy in the world and
of course to our police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers and Border Patrol
and Secret Service and all the first
responders out there you also make this
podcast possible by providing the safety
that we cherish in our great homeland
and to everyone else that is out there
remember some of those things that we
talked about today remember to make
maximum use of every hour and every
minute remember that a good tactician
has a constant sense of urgency we
should feel guilty when we're idle
guilty when were idle never waste time
and never be content never be content
with the pace at which things are
happening you should always try and
drive it faster time is important and we
have a absolute responsibility to make
things happen in order to do that
what you have to do is get up every day
and go get after it and until next time
this is Jocko and Dave out